[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
of the week
oh just go ahead and date this
[__] already oh
yesterday I mean Cochran
testified for Donald Trump court today
he's testifying against him apparently
um maybe you'll see Community I don't
know we'll see what's happening I think
the more important thing is the
communications that they're trying to
also get for the crime fraud exception
or whatever they're seeking some sort of
communication on a cell phone or
something it seems like uh Scott Perry
may be in big trouble I don't know
I don't know if you if you if you know
anything about the January 6th edition
case uh Pennsylvania
Congressman Scott Perry
was one of the key players
in the
um State electors fraud scheme
the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup where they
were trying to stall the results or
stall the certification of the results
like Toro College
Scott Perry was gonna deliver
the vice president Mike Pence the proper
electors and they were going to make
Donald Trump the dictator and King of
the United States a trump United States
of America the [__] out of here so and
we don't know exactly what that
communication is they're seeking we do
know that Scott Perry is trying to make
sure
that the federal authorities do not get
into his cell phone so we'll see maybe
that's the thing that's under seal I
don't know I mean I'd like to see that
as the right wing continues down this
road
uh they can't talk about anything but
Donald Trump's crimes and they're so
focused on the hush money payment
where Stormy Daniels and Donald Trump
the Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa
poopy pants himself is calling her
horsey face
dude you [__] her man you [__] her
or you tried to [__] her or you wanted
to [__] her now she's horsey come on man
horse face whatever
he's calling her come on give me a break
man
but they can't stop talking about porn
stars I don't know if you notice that
they're like porn star this porn star
that
and all the while putting meatball Ron
Ron tiny d
Ronnie D down the the fascist down in
Florida
uh he goes and does an interview with
Pierce Morgan on Fox news oh my God
oh my this this is not gonna go well
he says
he says I'm not running I'm running
against Joe Biden no you're not you fool
listen Rhonda Santos is not very good at
this okay he's just now he's good at
Florida politics
he knows how to stoke up the fascist in
Florida he loves the Nazis in Florida
folks he loves those Nazis in Florida
of course he's really good at it down
there he's just not very good at this
National thing
Ron Ron listen buddy I know I know
you're trying to create the situation
where you are running against Joe Biden
but Donald Trump is going to
[__] burn you down and piss on the
ashes tomorrow at Waco I'm excited
everyone is oh my God it's like he
should not be able to get on stage at
wait listen this Waco thing is gonna go
great for us folks
What What In Trump's world in the last
[__] three months has gone good for
him
and bad for us the pro-democracy
coalition
the people who are trying to save this
[__]
from these fascists taken over what has
gone well for him this Waco thing is
gonna be horrible for him here's what's
gonna happen I'll give you my prediction
of Waco right now right now
for some reason people think that this
is going to stoke up violence and
extremists listen listen it's all
[__] he doesn't actually have this
support
we would have seen this this last week
we would have watched them doing all
kinds of crazy [__] they're not doing it
they're showing up in an In-N-Out Burger
in costumes there's a few of them going
to New York
trying to figure out if people in
costumes and and doing satire and parody
are actually Trump supporters or not
that's how [__] confused these people
are
listen here's what is going to happen in
Waco
it is going to be the same old [__]
and a trump rally same old [__]
same sheep
penned up at Waco that's what it's gonna
be
guarantee it we're gonna have plenty of
video of these people saying really
stupid ignorant things that we can mock
now
the Cheeto does q and honor is gonna do
us a favor folks this week tomorrow at
Waco gonna do or whenever it is is it
tonight or is it tomorrow I don't know
does it really [__] matter when this
thing is when is this Waco thing is
anyone in the chat know
I I just know he's going to [__] Waco
is it tomorrow or is it or is it today
anyways it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
he's he's going to get on stage
and he's gonna do us a a couple [__]
favors here number one he is going to
call for violence against Democrats
liberals the Manhattan D.A special
counsel he is going to call for protest
and violence all around the country
that's what see it ain't gonna happen
it's Saturday people are saying tomorrow
yeah okay tomorrow but who gives a [__]
Sunday today Monday it doesn't [__]
matter when it happens it's gonna be
it's gonna be fantastic folks it's gonna
be fantastic
he's gonna get on stage and commit
crimes right out in the open it's only
gonna cause when when they do indict him
for a judge to have more reason to gag
that son of a [__] and not be able to
do these [__] things or or are
compel him not to say stupid [__]
like he was saying this morning there's
death and destruction death and
destruction you don't think he's gonna
get on stage and say that [__] of course
he is
he's a [__] lunatic this guy's out of
his [__] mind his marbles pack their
[__] and left
he didn't lose them they left
they're like they're looking for a
divorce the national divorce Marjorie
Taylor Green's been talking about it's
his it's Donald Trump and his marbles
are getting a [__] divorce
Melanie is jealous that his marbles get
to divorce him before she does
listen the other favor he's going to do
us here in Waco and this is gonna be
this is gonna be the part that you have
to pay attention to the most
he is absolutely going to set Ron
desantos on fire
burn him to the ground and piss and [__]
on his ashes he is going to destroy
Ronda Santa's career all in one Fell
Swoop this weekend I'm guaranteeing it
[__] Bet On It doubt me he is gonna
get on stage and he is gonna get this
small little crowd into a frenzy
over over Ron DeSantis and it's gonna be
[__] beautiful
because right right I don't know if you
noticed in this interview Ron Ron dude
dude you should have either waited to do
the interview or you should have went
hard after this [__] man I mean
I don't know who's doing your political
advising down there in Florida but they
[__] suck at this I mean they're
horrible at this
absolutely horrible
and and it's funny to watch uh
Republicans Trump Republicans try to
create space
uh for Ron to run
because Trump needs an opponent right
that's the only way that Trump does this
well he he does not do well when he's
unopposed he just looks like a [__]
lunatic
so he has to have someone to run against
and they're trying all kinds of people
now now that Ron desantos is very
vulnerable these Trump Republicans want
Ron DeSantis and the race
they want him in because they know Trump
will beat him
we I listened to it yesterday in another
Twitter space that we were in which
we're going to talk about today Jenna
Ellis was in this space and oh my God
Gabe Sanchez
Gabe Sanchez did this
he asked Jenna Ellis and he's going to
talk about it today I'm sure I'm sure
we're going to talk about this Gabe
Sanchez yesterday in a space I couldn't
talk I was listening
um but Gabe Sanchez asked Jenna Ellis if
she believed Donald Trump lost
[__] left the space immediately
she left she was gone she [__] she
bounced as soon as he asked her that
the entire room and I I don't remember
exactly what they were talking about
before that I think they were talking
about a porn stars and hush money right
because they can't stop talking about
porn stars and hush money here which is
fantastic don't let them lose that
narrative because that not is not the
plot line at all for the crime in the
Manhattan DA's office
that's why they're saying that [__]
listen let's let's touch on this for a
second the reason why it is so important
we talked to Rachel biddickoff for
yesterday the reason why it is so
important to keep these people talking
about hush money and porn stars is
because one that's not a winning message
at all
for P for for the for the 81 million
people that voted against him in the
2020 election that's not going to win
him any more [__] votes he's not
gonna lose him any votes maybe but it's
not gonna win him any more votes for
them to be out there like oh this hush
money payment was legal oh okay that's
weird that that's your [__] that's
your dig but here's the thing
the main ad DA's office all the
indication is from the grand jury is
that they're seeing evidence
they're seeing evidence of all the
crimes after the hush money payment
I I don't I can't figure out why they
keep focusing on the hush money payment
because that is likely not even going to
be in the charges like it's not even
going to be there so when these charges
it when and if they do drop from the
Manhattan D.A if the hush money payment
isn't in there their plot is broken
apart
now now they have to defend the crimes
that he did instead of now building this
this this and they're taking his lead
here folks this is all [__] this is
all crazy asinine [__] right but that's
why Waco is going to be good for us this
weekend I encourage listen I encourage
Donald Trump to get in front of a
microphone on a stage as much as he
possibly can right now do that [__]
go out stop stop typing it into true
social get out in front of a microphone
record that [__] broadcast it on
Trader TV News Network and and let's
make a [__] spectacle of this
let's do it if you want a [__] circus
let's invite the clowns and let's have a
party folks
that's what we need to do I know it
doesn't feel like it I know it feels
like oh my God Tony Jesus Christ you're
just encouraging this this [__] to
destroy our democracy no he's destroying
himself he's going to destroy Ronda
Santos he's going to destroy the
Republican party everything Trump
touches turns to liquid [__]
and the more he does it the worse it
gets today his [__] attorney who has
to defend him yesterday in court against
Jack Smith is now testifying to the
Grand Jury for Jack Smith
it's it we we are we are in the weirdest
[__] timeline we could ever possibly
be in folks but this is the reality of
our [__] state
we don't have a choice but to live in
the reality that we're in that's it
that's it but we must defend our
democracy at the same time
and we must be provided the ammunition
to do that and they're giving us all the
ammunition we [__] need
and I'm telling you Waco is gonna be a
fi it's gonna go over like a wet fart in
a white thong folks
Waco is not gonna make a hell of beans
worth a difference it's just not it's I
know the significance of Waco and the
anniversary and why he's going there and
what he's trying to do but folks he's
been trying to get people to protest and
commit violence for a week now
and they haven't [__] done it
they've done nothing because it doesn't
exist all the people who were willing to
commit violence for him already tried it
they [__] failed and a lot of them
are in [__] prison over it you
boneheads out there who think that this
Waco thing is gonna awaken some sort of
[__]
some sort of big movement to save him
from prosecutions is out of your minds
you're out of your minds it's gonna go
over like a wet fart in a white thong
and it's gonna make him look more like a
fool so let him [__] do it iced again
I say we should mandate this son of a
[__] to get in front of a microphone
every goddamn day
every single one of them that's that's
what we should do is mandate it
say crazy [__] in front of a microphone
Grandpa lunatic that'll go well for you
I'm sure
as Jack Smith moves in on these
obstruction charges and and really you
know
I'm not privy to any information but it
seems like to me what is happening
because uh if you just take the
um the idea and what you would know
about state and federal prosecutions and
who goes first
you know what's on second I don't know
who's on third what happens normally is
the feds always want to precede a state
indictment
the feds just have way more power in a
court
they have way they have just they just
have more [__] power
and and when and when especially when
you're talking about some of the crimes
that this [__] idiot has probably
committed
at one the one crime being obstruction
which I keep saying that the Manhattan
DA's office I think that's what the [__]
they're gonna charge him with they're
charging him with obstruction
that that investigation is not about
that hush money payment it is about all
the crimes that happened after that hush
money payment folks
come on
do you think do you think he committed
one crime and stopped criming are you
serious
you really believe that
that's why they keep focusing on the
hush money payment because the hush
money payment really not only is it
really not illegal
more than likely especially on a state
level
but who gives a [__]
I I really don't care if Donald Trump
paid someone to have sex with him I
don't care if he paid to have abortions
I don't give a [__] that is his business
and someone else's business it's when
you commit fraud to cover it up so that
way the American people don't know when
they're making decisions on who to elect
that's when it starts to get hairy and
then when you probably obstruct that
investigation of investigators looking
into that crime that's when it starts to
get hairy on the crime scene right
come on man
come on
that's the whole point who gives a [__]
about the hush money payment and besides
even even the hush money payment itself
seems like Matt's out of the [__]
statutes of limitation
but not the crime that was committed
afterwards
so who gives a [__] and really who cares
who goes first I would much rather Jack
Smith go first actually you know to be
to be upfront and honest I really would
love to see uh Fanny Willis go first to
beat going honest down in Georgia I
think the fanny Willis uh investigation
down in Georgia is going to crack open
the Republican party like you're not
never going to see before
I think that one's gonna show the entire
cards of racketeering because she's
going after racketeering and it's not
just Donald Trump that was racketeering
down in Georgia in the Georgia house
there was [__] afoot especially with
these State electors now Jack Smith may
be able to expose some of that too but I
think I think woo baby I think Georgia
she's going to lay the hammer I think
that's why Georgian politicians are
[__] scared that's why they passed
the law to try to get rid of Bonnie
Willis
No Doubt No Doubt
but when your attorney
when you're attorney
has to go test that is defending you
in front of a grand jury has to go
testify against you in front of that
grand jury oh buddy you are [__]
Capital
f-u-c-k [__] [__] [__] man that is
a horrible situation to be in Donald
Trump has put himself in this situation
and that is why I say let's do Waco I
can't wait I can't wait to see the clips
that are going to come out of Waco this
guy is going to say and do so much
stupid [__] and in the meantime he's
gonna destroy Ronda Santos
he's gonna destroy the pudding meatball
Ronnie tiny D it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
just watch
I'm going to show you some of this
footage from the uh I'm hoping we get
some of this footage we got bonehead of
the week people were mad oh they were
mad at me
can you imagine people being mad at me
no I don't know there I mean there are
some people that are pissed off their
tyt simps you know they love tyt oh they
[__] love t a loved him some Young
Turks
oh yeah there there they hold the
Democrats accountable Tony listen it's a
shtick you morons the whole holding
Democrats accountable over on tyt is a
stick
nothing more nothing less I'm gonna
prove it to you I'm gonna prove you that
Jank Unger has been doing this shtick
for years and years and years okay I'm
telling you I'm telling you now he was
on bone net of the week for a different
reason but I'm I when I put him on there
it was like what he do to you you know
you've been going after tyt for a while
what the [__] yeah [__] out of here
you're mad at you're mad at me for it's
it's funny because usually like hey tyt
and they go after and Anna they go after
the left okay well if they're on the
left and I'm going after them aren't I
going after the left too isn't that what
I'm doing you you people you people
really are [__] funny it's [__]
hilarious to watch you because I'm
telling you I'm telling you you may like
tyt now but they are fading out of
existence fast quick and in a hurry
and the reason why is because they're
they're capitulators in the demise of
our democracy if you don't believe me
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna show you [__]
evidence from 11 years ago where you
people should take this one little clip
and realize that Jank is nothing nothing
but a [__] it's all a stick the whole
[__] in caboodle when they're telling
you the Democrats are bad and all this
[__] I'm telling you now people were mad
that I put him on the bonehead and it's
not the thing at the evidence I'm going
to show you it's not it's not the reason
why he was on there but
the thing I'm going to show you is I'm
gonna show you uh has led up to the
reason why him well
he didn't really do the bone-headed
thing he defended the bone-headed thing
that happened which makes him even more
bone-headed I think it's it's crazy it's
crazy but but we'll go over that and
some people in the comments um are mad
at me
um and some people agree with me a tyt
it's a stick and some people are saying
David Pacman the same I've attacked
David Pacman too
um look listen the the reason why well
we'll just wait till bonehead of the
week or just wait till bonehead of the
week but I want to warn you if if you're
gonna be a snowflake on here today and
be really upset that I that I show you a
videotape
of of Jake Unger saying stupid [__] 11
years ago I'm gonna show it to you I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you the one reason
why you should not believe a [__]
word that guy says now you shouldn't
believe anything he says and really I
I'm not saying that he can't make up for
this right I'm not saying I'm saying
that he should he should change his ways
and he should stop the shtick he should
stop that and he should just do
commentary because he's been doing this
shtick for a long time
that that that that's that's right he's
but now again
some people are really pissed off at me
ah you're mad good stay here and be mad
all day long and wait you know what I do
I think I think I'm gonna wait I'm gonna
wait till the end to talk about tyt and
Jank and what him and Anna did uh on
social media what they're trying to do
because the thing they're trying to do
right now the thing the reason why
they're on bonehead of the week
the thing they're trying to do
is the same [__] that I'm gonna show you
he was doing 11 years ago their feet
they're feeling out the playing field
they're trying to they're trying to see
if Their audience is going to be with
them or not
they're trying to see what they can get
away with and what they can't get
they're not just being genuine they're
not just saying what the [__] they feel
or what the hell they think right
it's all a stick
and it's and it's a stick to get you to
watch so they can sell you [__] I don't
know if you ever watched they're trying
to sell you [__]
you know and that's media media in
general we listen Us in the independent
meeting we have to make a living we have
to because we don't have they always say
George Soros [__] pays us and [__] we
don't have big huge billionaires that
give us a bunch of [__] money just to
talk into microphones like right Wingers
like Steve Bannon Steve Bannon is
[__] funded by a bunch of [__]
billionaires so that he can yell and
scream fashion [__] into a microphone we
don't get paid to do that [__]
we don't
we don't get paid to do that [__] we
have to [__] we have to earn our keep
and actually get people to watch get
[__] eyeballs and sell advertising or
get you to get you to to buy some
different content I mean there's a lot
of different ways to monetize this stuff
but for us to make a living that's the
[__] we got to do to keep doing it
so I don't begrudge tyt for
commercializing and and making making
their tyt model the corporate media
because they are but you know and and
it's more of a Infowars style type stuff
but you know again I'm not I'm not
hating too much on that because I sell
the hats I sell merch you guys you guys
go and you you you are members of
patreon where I do extra content over
there to help support us you you you
link your Prime account to your Twitch
account that gives us some money right
all this stuff all this stuff monetizes
it so we can make a living because this
is our job so I'm not hating on that
what I'm saying is that they're using
their [__] platform to hurt democracy
not help it when they claim they're
helping it that's the thing that pisses
me off that's the thing that really
pisses me off
is that they're they're claiming they're
trying to help it but they're actually
hurting it and maybe they don't know it
but I think they know it and I I believe
that it's a stick so we're gonna go over
that today so stay tuned if you love tyt
stick around you're going to be pissed
off if you hate tyt trust me you're
gonna love it
oh you're gonna love it baby
so that that'll be in bonehead of the
week all right hey speaking of
monetization you you know what you
should do
you should go check out patreon.com the
Tony Michaels while I'm speaking of you
know making money
this is a perfect opportunity if you got
if you got if you want to have some
extra content we're going to do the
Sunday rant and the Sunday chant I'm
going to ask me anything last week we
did it on Friday in the afternoon I
think I'm gonna do it probably tomorrow
though I'm gonna try out some different
times for ask me anything I'm trying to
figure out when's the best time to do it
to be quite honest
um when is the for you guys when's the
best what what well meet in the middle
good for me good for you to do ask me
anything here's an ask me anything is
it's kind of like shoot the [__] here on
the show
but we get together for 30 minutes you
can ask me any question you want
any [__] question you want I will
answer it personal politics it's mostly
politics but whatever you want trust me
last week's and if you join patreon go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels you can
re-watch last week's I answered every
single question even the ones that you
wouldn't think I would answer I answer I
answer
I answer
those questions so go check out
patreon.com the Tony Michaels become a
member we'll do an ask me anything I
believe tomorrow and then of course the
Sunday rant on Sunday also you know what
you if you're here on the YouTube
channel don't forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel it's free
it's free don't cost you a single nickel
so download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google that's free 99 over
there too doesn't cost you a nickel and
you can download it on all the platforms
if you want follow us on Facebook that
didn't cost you a single nickel if you
still have a Facebook account at the
Tony Michaels subscribe to the up wires
YouTube channel just go to the
upwire.com or type in the up wire on
YouTube subscribe over there we stream
over there as well and there's some
great content creators on that Network
as well also again if you have if you
have a Twitch account and you have an
Amazon Prime account or if you don't
have a Twitch account and you got an
Amazon Prime account goes open a Twitch
account you can link those two and give
us your one free subscription that comes
with Amazon
your Amazon Prime account and we get a
few bucks of Amazon's money so we get a
few dollars of the billionaire Jeff
bezos's money you're saying if you don't
like billionaires you want to give me a
few of their dollars and it doesn't cost
you a thing you can do that and I think
we're almost at 100. let's shoot for a
hundred I think we're uh we're at 80 80
80 80 85 85 86 something like that over
there oh and by the way
uh someone's uh typing this in we are
almost a fifteen thousand on YouTube so
if you're right now if you're I don't
care what platform you're on go over to
YouTube go to the Tony Michaels podcast
Channel hit subscribe we're so close the
fifteen thousand I mean we're less than
100 away so if there's there's like 50
of you out there
if there's 50 of you out there I think
we're less than 25 away actually let's
go take a look let's go confirm I don't
want to tell you wrong I only deal in
fact holy [__]
oh man we need 13. 13 to get to 15 000.
where's those 13 at
13 roll of lucky number 13. so if you
aren't a subscriber to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube make sure to go over
and subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube uh I'm gonna bring in
Gabe Sanchez here I think he's gonna be
ready he's working on bonehead of the
week we also have bonehead Madness that
he wants to tell you about stick around
uh we're gonna be right back with the
talk about Jenna Ellis in this space and
how she bounced as soon as Gabe Sanchez
asked the question did Trump lose the
2020 election everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it's Friday
Oh Nana of the week we got bonehead
Madness it's gonna happen over the
weekend
[Music]
so we're in the Sinister 16.
a bonehead Madness
Gabe Sanchez will be posting that on and
on at Tony Michael's pod on Twitter so
go follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod
on Twitter you'll be able to vote on
each bracket and each match up
on the bonehead Madness bone end of the
week
oh well you probably know who ran away
with the bonehead of the week
oh boy of course he did of course he did
what other news do we have today
um
I I'm gonna talk to you about a space
that we were in you know we've been
doing these Twitter spaces with these
ranked Wingers uh Seb Gorka Sebastian
Gorka and Tom Fenton's been in a couple
of them yesterday and uh Marie Giuliani
appeared in one that I was in uh Leb
Parnes he dropped the bomb that Hunter
Biden's laptop was stolen from him in
Kazakhstan where he was drugged that's
what he claims
I don't and he says he has the proof of
it so we'll see if Leb Parnes
um gets the proof
let
Hunter Biden was drugged in Kazakhstan
he was fed drugs and given hookers to
distract him while they stole his laptop
and copied his hard drive and then took
it over to Delaware to this repair shop
where Hunter Biden's attorneys is
apparently sued the uh
the repair shop the owner you know this
guy he's got the funny hat he shows up
on Fox News and all these Traders TV
news networks you know what I'm talking
about that game
uh Hunter apparently has sued him
um for being the uh being
for defamation but also making up the
story about how he got the laptop and
[__] like that so
um that's interesting very very very
interesting stuff that like Barnes but
yesterday Jenna Ellis
um was in a space Benny Johnson was in
this space Oh my God
yeah listen these stupid bastards and
then and then before I bounce because it
they kept talking about Carrie Lakes
lawsuit did you hear this Carrie Lake
lost again in the Arizona Supreme Court
the Supreme Court kicked the decision
back down to a lower court
um and it is she loses [__] again
she's not she's not gonna be Governor
okay they're not they're not gonna
they're not gonna overturn
the [__] Governor's election it's
already March 24th man it's not going to
happen
it was free it was fair there's no
you're just bitching because people were
in line that's that's not the reason why
you lost you're just bitching because
someone had to go from one Precinct to
the other that's not the reason why you
lost that's a reason maybe to look into
Arizona's uh the way they do elections
because everyone everyone agrees that
Arizona takes forever to [__] count
they take forever and what it does when
they do these [__] stupid things
here's what it does it it gives people
like Carrie Lake Donald Trump all these
[__] seditious traitor Nazis time to
soad out into our elections that's all
it does that's all it does and and
that's why in this space they kept
talking about oh we need single day
voting on paper ballots and all kinds of
crazy ass [__] that makes no sense
because what they want to do is limit
the amount of voting they want to limit
it they don't want to expand it they
want to limit it
there is a way to expand voting to where
everyone votes and everyone gets their
[__] vote counted on time in a timely
manner where it doesn't take days and
weeks to figure out who's won a certain
Precinct or who's won a certain election
in a state it's stupid [__] we can we
can do this the problem in Arizona the
reason why it's so [__] up in Kerry
Lake and all these Republicans are
bitching is because Republicans had
their hands on the legislator they've
had their hands on a legislator for two
goddamn decades and the legislators the
one who sets laws for how the state
votes that's the other stupid argument
they were making in this stupid [__]
space and you're going to continue to
hear this stupid [__] from these people
leading up to 2024 that the legislators
have the right to the vote and to the
electors no they do not the legislator
doesn't get to decide who gets the
electors they get to decide how the
state
selects the electors now if they give
themselves that power sure but almost
every single state does not does not
give the legislator the power to pick
the electors that's not how it [__]
works in Most states and every state is
different and these [__] boneheads
continue to talk and talk and talk and
say stupid [__] [__] that they know
nothing about and some of these
[__] in that space do know what
they were talking about they're just
[__] spreading lies that's all
they're trying to do and they're trying
to use it with big words and Jenna Ellis
is [__] one of them it's crazy
it's [__] crazy she was in this space
at one point now Gabe Gabe went up to
speak and he's going to talk about it
when he gets on but he got up to speak
and he asked her one question did Trump
lose the 2020 election and she [__]
bounced she got out of the room now she
came back later
she came back later and I wasn't able to
talk I was only able to listen
um for the majority of the time
yesterday
and when she came back there was another
person in the room
Who challenged her
on
her her [__] her statement she had to
file with a a court with a judge in
Colorado where she admitted
admitted 10 times to line she in this
space she said I that is a lie that is a
lie that is like the gang got the
[__]
he got the goddamn declaration that she
had to sign to keep her law license in
Colorado that's her home state Colorado
that's where her her law license is
that's the bar that has the jurisdiction
over her law license as it were the
authority over her long license
they can pull it from her just like they
have City pal Rudy Giuliani Lynn wood
and several others it looks like some of
them are going to lose it in Arizona
over this Kerry Lake [__] because it's
stupid [__]
it's dumb [__] you can't you can't
ignore how the law Works to try to
deceive the courts when you're an
attorney it's just something you cannot
do
and Jenna Ellis in the space because
it's not a court
because there's no legal ramifications
for her saying stupid [__] out while I'm
doing to a microphone just in public not
in a court there's no ramifications for
that it's our first amendment she can
say stupid [__] and lies all she wants
she claimed that she didn't say what's
in the legal declaration that she had to
sign for a goddamn Colorado judge in the
room she was like no that's a lie that's
a lie the guy's like I'm reading the
[__] and it's got your signature
on it it's got your Goddamn signature on
it and she continued to lie but that is
what we're dealing with folks these
people are Shameless they're not gonna
stop they're not they're not gonna quit
they're not gonna quit trying to trying
to get rid of our democracy they're not
gonna do it
and and it's and the battle is on a lot
of fronts
and that's what they love about the
culture War right because they're always
blaming the culture war on us the
Liberals but Liberals are like what are
you talking about we just want people to
[__] we just want you to leave people
alone
just leave [__] alone and let's
concentrate on issues that are affecting
Americans that they give a [__] about
like like
not [__] going bankrupt over a
medical bill that would be nice earning
a decent [__] wage that would be nice
um I don't know go to college without
having to [__] pay for a hundred
years on the college debt
um I don't know have your kids start
their education at three instead of five
so parents can pay for two years less of
the most
outrageous cost
in early childhood daycare
uh I don't know feed children in schools
all of them three times a day
all every single kid every one of them
just just feed them like food you know
so they're not hungry these simple
[__] things are easy to say easy to
do most Americans agree with this [__]
we are not divided on these issues give
me a [__] break
go ask any go ask any manga supporter if
they want to go bankrupt over a medical
bill just say it just like that ask them
that question do you want to go bankrupt
because of them and go hell no Hail to
the no they'll tell you that what what
they're what they're actually saying is
they want the government to make sure
that just because they have a medical
situation whatever it is
that they're not they're they're their
livelihood isn't at risk because of
something they can't control
I'm telling you they're going to be on
your side
but this this is the crazy ass [__] that
they're they're having a culture war on
all fronts
with education we had Jess Piper on
they're using the voucher system and
they're and they're using trans children
to take away parents consent
that's what they're doing they they
won't they're so far down this book band
hole
again this book ban it's not it's not
about the books it's about the consent
think about it think about this for a
second they're they're banning The Diary
of Anne Frank so when they ban this uh
this this diary from the library they're
taking away your consent to let your
child see it because they're going
they're not just going after public
libraries I mean libraries in school
they're going after the public libraries
in the community
they they want religious they want
religion to dictate what's in our public
libraries
they're trying to pass legislation I'm
telling you they're not going to stop
and they're not going to stop at your
parental consent they're going to come
after your [__] bodily autonomy
they started with women in Roe v Wade
and now they they don't want rape
they don't want incest exemptions
that's coming after bodily autonomy well
they're not going to stop at women
they're not going to stop there I mean
that's that's the Target that they love
to attack
because of abortion but their abortion
services but they're not going to stop
there Jesus Christ
they're in Texas
and that's in in in in the federal
judge's desk on in Texas they're trying
to get rid of
a medication
an abortion service that is used 50
around the country the 50 of abortion
services around the country are trying
to get rid of that with one Fell Swoop
but you don't think they'll come after
you
they don't you don't think they'll come
after your Liberty you don't think
they'll come after your parental consent
well I don't have a trans child I don't
have a child that's in the lgbtq
community so what do I have to worry
about that's right stand back
and let them take away their those
people's Liberty those parents consent
and see how they treat your consent just
just do it I'm telling you if you do not
defend
other people's Liberty in this country
they will come after yours that's what
these culture wars are about
that's what they're about they're about
fascism and they're about pushing
fascism they were talking about in this
space that we should have paper ballots
and only paper ballots this is dumb [__]
this is stupid [__] [__] these are
the same people who think crypto a
digital currency is the best thing since
sliced bread and they can't trust a
[__] digital vote a digital ballot
but they but the digital currency is the
only way get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense you people are out of your
gourds
they've just lost their minds they don't
make any sense and they're not supposed
to really
they're not supposed to they're like
like this Jenna Ellis you know Jen
Alice's right she's the one that ran
around the country with Rudy Giuliani
Rue Giuliani farted on her in Michigan
you remember this he farted on her and
gave her covid that's Jen Ellis she's
the one her and Rudy Giuliani went to
Rusty Bowers
who is the former speaker of the Arizona
house
right
he he testified in front of the January
6 select committee and said that Rudy
Giuliani and Jenny Ellis came to him
they flew to Arizona to meet with him
and when he asked them for the [__]
evidence
that there was fraudulent votes they
couldn't produce it they're like well
you know it uh um some it's underneath
Trump's mattress probably that's
probably where it is either that or
Dinesh D'Souza has the footage of it
it's really stupid [__]
it's not supposed to make sense and the
reason why is because it's fraud it's
fraud Jenna Ellis committed fraud she
was lying to Federal she was lying about
Federal elections
two two State officials to try to get
them to do fraudulent [__]
that's what happened
that's why she was reprimanded in
Colorado that's why she had to admit to
10 different lies that she told to keep
her [__] license or her
are the ability for her to practice law
in Colorado joining us is the person who
really uh scared Jenna Ellis
terrified her with one one question it
was a rough question though I'm out of
the mid it is a really tough question
Gabe Sanchez is joining us now Gabe uh
it was a tough question I don't know
what to say it's funny because um I
don't remember what what the room was
talking about something right so what
happened was Joe Walsh was asking well
basically Joe Walsh was like Hey look
I've heard a lot of you guys say some
stupid [__] uh and what I'm gonna what
I'm gonna say is like which is like the
theme of these rooms oh awesome
it's just garbage man just Salvage so
basically what happens is uh Joe's like
look I'll say one thing and uh you can
go on talking but uh what I do want to
point out is the fact that
um
we he was like we don't know
we don't know what the charges are but
also
um the phone call in Georgia is that
like that's the thing that we should all
be focusing on like that's like whether
or not you think this this charge in New
York is gonna hold or whatever is like I
don't think that's a big thing I think
the call in Georgia is something and we
should acknowledge the fact that what he
did was as a sitting president tried to
interfere with the election to benefit
himself right well and and in that the
question is did Donald Trump believe
that he won or lost right right because
that's that's where that's where the
motive comes in for some of these crimes
exactly did he know and did he believe
he lost or not and was was he using the
information that he knew he lost he was
trying to overturn the election even
though he he lost right and that's when
you asked and that's when I came in and
I gave this kind of I was like I don't
want to jump into it too quick so I
basically was like look there's the
theme here that I think we need to
acknowledge it's the fact that Donald
Trump lies and he uses it to incite his
base and I think I think you've rattled
off about 10 or 12 examples of this yeah
yeah and and what I said so and what
what I said was uh I was like we knew we
need to acknowledge that Trump lies
whenever he can and he does so to incite
his base and also to grift I mean fund
raise off oh that was great that really
pissed him off oh yeah this pit that
little like I mean uh not sorry not
gripped uh fundraise
it was a it was a slip though right you
it had no intention in him no I had no
intention of saying grift right uh but
the people people in the comments were
like oh my god did you see how
disparaging he was against Trump saying
that he gripped it I was like yeah the
whole [__] point of why I said what I
said you know what's funny is the one
comment you sent me the guy's like poor
form I'm like all right Seb I get that
you're in there with your [__] sock
puppet account yeah because that sounds
like what something's said Gorka would
say poor form
I don't say you know I chose my words
carefully on this and when I said grift
I intended it to have the slip and say
grift I mean fundraise off
because it was just it was just
mentioned I think earlier in the call
that he had raised a million and a half
or something like that right like he had
raised money and people people were like
we got to acknowledge the fact that this
guy lied about a bunch of stuff and I
said I uh what I and what I said was I
was like look he's lied on many things I
was like whether it was him getting
arrested and he fundraised off on that
fact on Tuesday or it was the fact that
he said that he had sent the FBI down to
Florida to help uh Ron DeSantis in 2018
which we know has been debunked by the
FBI or you go all the way to the big lie
in pushing
um the 2020 election right and it was it
was actually good that that Joe had
mentioned Georgia before this because I
was like oh great this is a good segue
here and I was like Joe mentioned this
and since Jenna is on the call I really
have one question for her and that is
did Donald Trump lose the 2020 section
and then she was like and then I backed
up because I was like look I'll let you
answer and if you go back and you listen
to her answer it's a bunch of [__]
word gibberish where she's like well I
mean what we really need to look at is
all the cases that were involved in the
2020 election and we're unfairly not
able to get our actual cases seen or
litigated in the courts and this and
this and that
and then she's like oh well based on the
main you know it was the whole thing she
wasn't answering the question and right
as she like and I finished the question
I was like so is that a yes or a no she
goes I gotta go right now I gotta jump
with the call I gotta I gotta leave I
gotta go to this other thing you know
and then boom left right and and I was
like it's just it's just a yes or no is
it is it a yes or or no did he lose the
election
and then she you know she's like okay
bye I gotta go you know and then they
wouldn't let you continue in the room to
talk about it because she wasn't in
there I'm like what the [__] [__] just
because she's not in the room this she's
not a commentator on this right right
and that's that's the thing in the room
and again
um we talked to Ed the other day and I I
I I I mean I respect Mario letting us
come in the room and say our piece right
A lot of times but I'll tell you it has
it has an overtone to it and really
honestly this this idea that Jenna Ellis
is some kind of commentator on this
stuff Jenna Ellis is an accomplice in
the crime of them trying to [__]
defraud the American people in January
6. I don't give a [__] what you say she
she was there with Rudy all around the
country going to legislators trying to
convince them to overturn your election
and your results and using fraud they
said they had evidence and they did not
have it right so then I know that for
sure with Rusty so this is this is what
happens so that happened she leaves and
they're they're continuing to talk right
and they're like oh well they said she
they said uh she told us before that she
had to leave but she'll come back and I
was like okay whatever you say I'm gonna
go with the fact that she left early
whether or not she was already planning
to leave she definitely left early after
I asked that question and keep in mind
okay so then this is what happened so
then she comes back later on right and
the conversation at this point I've
pretty much like lit a [__] fire and
I've backed away because you weren't
even talking at that point you were just
up on the stage but they were all
talking about winning and losing winning
numbers you kind of got into it with the
Jim what's his name what's this guy's
name
or whatever yeah Jim fluffer That's his
name so he thinks he knows about
elections but he was saying all kinds of
[__] that just ain't true he was like
legislators are the ones who determine
the winner I'm like you were so full of
[__] yeah that is not true at all
legislators have the ability to to to it
was it was it was absolute nonsense
because he came on he came on the stage
and was talking and I was like look
you gotta you gotta acknowledge the fact
that the Republican party you know they
they want to have their cake and eat it
too right they they want to have mail-in
votes at one point but then they don't
because it's now it's available to
everyone during the pandemic and that's
unfair so and then he was like oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa what and I was like yeah
Republicans have pushed forward or have
been big proponents and fans of mail-in
ballots and he's like whoa I've been
working on uh elections for years and I
was like yeah and I was like hey look
Jim that's a great anecdote but unless
you have data four here's then that's
all it is
here's what he's doing here's what he's
doing and I want I want the audience to
be clear on this because this is this is
the lie that Jim is telling you because
what he what he and he said it later on
he's like I'm not talking about absentee
ballots that's different those are
requested ballots that appear in a
mailbox so if you're okay with a
requested ballot appearing in the
mailbox why are why are you so against a
a a a ballot appearing in a mailbox that
they mail everyone their ballot it's
it's it [__] boggles my mind in in
our state in Missouri because I that's
the only thing that I can speak to right
right is when you register in the state
of Missouri they register you at your
address it has to be a physical address
that you're registered at the one of the
reasons why is because they got to know
where you're voting like for Road
districts school boards you know all the
local elections of what what Precinct or
District or where where your
representation is right they got to know
where your representation is and who
you're voting on what ballot and where
you're going to vote but but they mail
you they mail you a [__] card that
says hey you're registered and here's
your registration you know have this
when you go vote you know what I mean so
so they mail that to you and and this is
the fallacy they actually are are gas
lining people to believe that an
absentee ballot where someone requests
whether it's military
um someone who has a medical condition
maybe someone who's going to be out of
the country for whatever reason or out
of can't vote at their at their local
ballot place because they're on a
[__] business trip or something in a
different state whatever the reason is
there's a lot of different reasons you
can request an absentee ballot in States
but what they're saying is that's okay
to mail to a person but but another
ballot is not okay to mail so that's the
distinction he's making and the reason
why he's making that is because
Republicans have always they invented
the absentee ballot and the reason why
they invented the absentee ballot is so
because a lot of times the absentee
ballot is their vote right
but if you're going to be able to mail
people a ballot for absentee reason you
should be able and the state legislators
under his logic who get to decide how
the state votes in these elections
should be able to decide that you know
what all citizens are going to be able
to vote by mail and we're just going to
mail them a ballot now they can either
use that ballot they can bring that
ballot in on Election Day or they can
vote on Election Day and we just don't
count the mail-in ballot and it works
that way it actually works there's no
evidence to suggest anywhere and they
couldn't provide it and they won't be
able to provide it right the only thing
they say is and this was their argument
well you need to vote on one day and one
day only yeah and you need to vote on
paperback what is this the [__] 1700s
their their argument yet so their
argument when when we know because I got
into it with this guy Jim right and I've
gotten into it the last few times where
Jim goes into this whole like uh
constitutional type of monologue where
he's like based on this Clause this blah
blah sub paragraph whatever and it's
like all right Jim look I know that you
may think that you you got [__] big
balls because you know that or at least
you can regurgitate the Constitution
whether it's in front of you on your
[__] mantle piece or not the idea
that you think because again like it
started with
Republicans the GOP rely heavily on
mail-in votes okay and he was like no no
no I work I I live in FL I live in
Colorado and I work elections and I go
okay but you're you're I don't know what
elections you've you've helped with
years it's like I've got all these years
and I was like what do you know Gabe and
I was like you can't read Gabe you can't
read and use deductive reasoning and
logic I was like look if you can I was
like this is because I was like look I'm
gonna call this what it is it's an
anecdote and an anecdote is only good as
like the source it comes from and you're
only giving me one person yourself
telling me that oh uh the Republican
Party The GOP doesn't has never pushed
for mail-in mail-in ballots right in
mail-in voting so so then I was like you
know what fine uh I was like show your
proof show your proof he's like I don't
have to you came in with a clue and I
was like fine you know what I will go
and I will find it and I will send it to
Mario and the team right so at this
point I then I go into and the reason I
backed off for a minute is because I got
into it with uh with Jen Ellis again and
she was and there was a question that
came up and she was like well the merits
on the court meanwhile Tony and I again
are texting the background yeah and he
was like never yeah yeah so I was I was
because I couldn't talk so I was yelling
at you in a text message to [__] open
your mic up and jealous into the mic and
you're like no no kick me out so so yeah
so then I was like she was like oh the
merits on this was like what merits and
she was like oh the the merits of the
case the merits of what we have and then
I was like okay but shoot and then and
then and then I asked her this question
which she was unwilling to and got very
pissed off about as well it was when she
was talking about the cases and brought
forward and no one was even willing to
look at them and I was like oh there's
this many there's 86 judges I had Margie
also texting me who was like hey check
this out here's this link you know this
and that right and uh and and and I was
like look
was there evidence did you do you have
evidence that there was voter fraud do
you have evidence
and at that point I had the the Mario
and the team were like hey uh we gotta
you know you gotta cool it on the
questions
and in my mind I'm like no if you're
gonna come in here right and spit this
type of misinformation and and tell
people that oh it was actually this and
not that and you have been censured by
this in Colorado and you had admitted
that you had lied on 10 different
occasions but then all of a sudden
you're gonna try and you can look this
up people there's NPR there's a PBS
there's a Daily Beast there's a ton of
New York Times I think is the one that
broke the story but she admitted on 10
different occasions that she had lied
and she had to yeah she had your license
and then and they gave her they gave her
like a little warning strike because uh
it was her first offense which I was
like holy [__] you just spent months
trying to push the idea of the big lie
you should not at all have the ability
to have your license you [__] ticket
traffic cop court it's [__] she's an
ambulance Jason yeah she's it's it's
well the best part was when and I don't
know who it was that came in the room
but he actually had several of the court
cases
um that she was claiming weren't well
there was there was Tyra also came yes
Tire also and I I would like to have
Tyler on the show
Tyler's great she always has receipts
and she was going after and really
um more politely than I would have yeah
she was much more polite with General
Ellison I if I was in the room they
probably would have bounced me because
and they probably would not invite me
back because I would have said why are
you commentating on this you're not a
commentator on this you're not looking
from the outside you were part of the
you were part of the big lie you were
trying to steal our election you were
actively in you're you're in the January
6 testimony over and over and over again
as part of the fraud that there was a
stolen election right not Stalin the The
Fruitcake from Germany to be confused
the stolen election that you tried to
steal we know that now yeah
um so but the thing was is this other
person came in and basically went
through the 10 lies that Jenna Ellis had
to admit to and he said and she's like
that's a lie that's like he's like I'm
looking at your signature oh yeah yeah
I'm looking at your signature right now
I'm looking at it right now I can see
your signature on this declaration that
you admitted to these lies and she's
like oh that's all deep and went to the
Deep State now it's the government so
she had so what she was claiming without
saying it out loud is that she lied
here's what I think she's claiming and
and I think it's it's code right yeah
it's this code word [__] that they try
to use deep State and all this [__]
what she's trying to say is that she
just agreed to that so that they let her
keep her law license she didn't actually
believe it when she signed it which is
[__] fraud which is gonna get her in
more trouble so I hope she keeps talking
that's why I keep telling everyone these
people talking like this and saying this
[__] out loud is gonna get him in more
and more trouble and we see that today
with and with uh Corcoran and we're
gonna get to it in bone in a week having
to testify against Donald Trump the day
after he had to go testify for him this
is [__] nuts the other thing that's
um I think I think is going to be
um big news I think is going to be
as Dash Nebraska is a big news good news
big news oh boy
um yeah I need we need to get Dash on
the show we really should so people know
the context of what we're saying I think
some people know Dash but we need to get
him on the show I love that game
um he's crazy that's why I like him um
here's here's the thing is that there is
something in under seal that um is
trying to be appealed we know that Scott
Perry was trying to make sure that the
federal authorities did not get into his
cell phone and apparently whatever this
is under seal they're trying to get into
an electronic device or some sort of
communication it seems like that's what
it is and that's one thing it could it
could be though because John Eastman had
a lot of electronics taken
um what's the other Jeffrey um oh Jesus
I you know so many Traders how can you
uh keep track of these uh names you know
the guy that he's trying to point to be
the Attorney General remember yeah
um
anyways all these characters in this
thing I'd have to look it up there's so
many anyways but I I believe that it's
probably Scott Perry's phone that that
this uh appeal for these communications
to be taken off this electronic device
whatever it is it seemed that's what the
report is it that there's Communications
it's undersealed they're not sure who it
is or why they want it or why why the
special counsel is seeking this but they
do know it has some Jeffrey Clark that's
it yeah
the guy who who got his house searched
and he was out in his driving underwear
yeah with underwear yeah that's all I
could see is him in his underwear I
couldn't see his name yeah that's
probably what it was his uh his
underwear
um so we're gonna get into and we're
going to get into some of the the
Cochran thing but uh you got an
announcement to make before we get the
bone of the week we're going to be doing
um bonehead Madness tell everyone about
Madness yes okay so we got bonehead
manners I put up the poll or I'm sorry I
put up the uh here I'll actually put it
up right now
uh hold on oh are you gonna live tweet
the bonehead Madness I'll tweet it in a
second I'm exporting the uh the video
for bonehead Madness
um
but I'll put up the actual I made a
couple changes I put it up yesterday but
then I was like ah I wanted to
I wanted to have certain people in there
and I saw people ask for it so I was
like you know what before we make it
live they're making good some good
points here so I want to add it yeah he
was asking me this morning I'm like I
don't give a [__] what'd you do I said
what I said I said I said Mercury Taylor
green is probably gonna win anyways
right right so this is the uh this is it
right here so we've got Ted Cruz uh
Marcia Blackburn uh Lindsey Graham I
threw in Rick Scott and replaced him
with uh instead of Josh Hawley we got
Michael J Knowles Sean Hannity uh we got
uh Tucker Carlson Candace Owens I put
her in last minute uh because of some
recent stuff that she did she was very
uh very it's made some very ableist type
of comments Margie Taylor green of
course Kevin McCarthy Jim Jordan in The
Honorable George Santos Ron DeSantis
Donald Trump Jr Donald Trump and Nick
Fuentes so who knows we could see a
father-son duel or we could see a
presidential duel in the [__] waffles
yet to be seen but either way I'm going
to be throwing that up in a second I
made a couple Corrections and then after
that I'll have the poll uh there there
will be two polls today and then we'll
do another two pulls tomorrow right and
the NCAA is in the sweet 16 so we're in
the Sinister 16. we're going to try to
stay like uh arm and arm with it because
it's not March Madness we can't call it
that we can't call it March Madness we
cannot cover that's why it's bonehead
men bonehead Madness
[__] [__] them uh because if we call it
if here's the thing if we did call it
March Madness something then they could
try to you know stop us from doing it
but because we're not calling it March
Madness and we can't call it March
Madness and that's why we call it
bonehead Madness that we're able to get
away with it so and again if yeah I'll
tell the audience this if Marjorie
Taylor green wins yeah next year we will
call it Marge we did it last year and
she lost she lost and so we couldn't
call it Marge Madness but we can't call
it if she wins this year we'll do it
we'll call it Marge Madness Marge
Madness March Madness
our such [__] [__] them I don't
[__] care yeah we're all [__]
traitors [__] them all right
oh my god
um what other what other piece of news
do we have before we get about oh I nope
wait I got something I want to show you
yeah speaking speaking of your friend
Seb oh okay oh speaking of your friend
said I found this um this morning I
think Ron posted Belinda had it um on
her her Twitter page here is um and it
says what a cretan
um but it's that's what I said he loves
to use that word does he know that word
is French does he know that I have no
idea but the the the the fact that he
says that and
it's his go-to like I've I've been
called the
ER I will say this in the last week
alone I've heard the word cretan more
times than I can imagine in my whole
life and everything from him and every
time they've been said it's been from
him to me that's hilarious because at
one point like he tried to jump in on
top you're like Seb let me finish my
point and then you can call me a creden
yeah and he's like it's crutching you
know it's like and I was like oh sorry
it's [__] and then I got actually I
got a bunch of laugh emojis at the time
that people were responding right well
that's because he's an asshat yeah I
don't know I don't know if you guys know
this
um the history behind this guy I didn't
know this I was talking to a friend of
mine that's
um uh from from that part of Europe and
um he said no he's from Hungary this
guy's Hungarian right yeah he's now he's
a British Hungarian yeah he's British
which is yeah but he's British Hungarian
sevengulka but he loves he loves Orban
because he's a Hungarian Nazi is what he
is yeah he loves that's what Seb Gorka
is he's a fascist from Hungaria so but
I'm hungry excuse me there's a Hungarian
he's a hungry fascist right he is a
hungry yeah yeah hungry so let's listen
to The Hungry bashes talk about porn
stars they can't stop talking about porn
stars man I love it and he's going after
the Santas here which is even more juicy
oh my God it's so great listen and then
in the press conference on Monday on
another topic he's asked and he does
this snarky thing twice he has to talk
about harsh money for porn stars twice
and get Giggles from the peanut gallery
it's an NDA Ron I signed an NDA with
President Trump in 2015 and I ain't no
porn star I wonder what he had to do to
Donald Trump to get an NDA you think he
you think he uh I think who I don't know
I mean I'm not against it hey whatever
you whatever you got to do whatever you
got to do to get ahead Seb I mean I'm
not against it that's yeah whatever you
got to do to get ahead right or give or
give whatever you whatever you want to
do
say your consent or what your consent
was and what it was for that's fine I
get it that's cool I'm just saying Ron
DeSantis is a cretan
critics
yeah I think I think it's I think he he
pronounces it [__] [__] yeah because
I said [__] right he's like Greek
right in in Missouri
yeah [__] [__] you [__] green
right but yeah Seb what an asshat but I
I'll tell you I love this uh battle
um DeSantis and Trump because they can't
figure it out even in this space right
even in the space they can't figure out
uh because even yeah yesterday they were
like oh well is he gonna run is it not
and that's how I actually started my
point I was like look if anyone was
watching the 2022 gubernatorial debates
happening in Florida you knew and you
should know that Ron DeSantis was
already planning to win he could
couldn't answer the simple question of
are you going to run for president in
the 2024 election because he couldn't
answer that you know that that was
something that was already in his head
and all these stops and this tour and
this and that and doing these these
interviews it's all part of the fact
that in December 2022 the Florida
legislator was already considering to
revoke or repeal the um
the if you run you have to resign law so
like you can't tell me that this guy
isn't planning to run I mean these
[__] leaving breadcrumbs for everyone
to follow and people are like oh he's
not gonna run and it's like dude if he's
gonna run he's it's get he should do it
sooner than later obviously because his
chances are better but he's getting
Windows is closing here and and I I
here's what I think because I said this
in the first 30 minutes that this Waco
rally there's there's there's there's
two really good things that are gonna
get well three but two really good
things that are gonna come out of trump
getting on stage and just saying
whatever the [__] he wants number one
he's he's gonna talk about all kinds of
crime that he's done and he's gonna he's
just gonna give a judge somewhere once
he's indicted more reason to give him a
gag order which is gonna piss him off
even more which is going to make him say
even more crazy [__] right which is
gonna make him unelectable at best I
mean in the general election but he's
not in that cycle he's in it he's in a
Republican primary and his his most
formidable opponent is desantos that's
why he's been he's been attacking him in
the last 24 hours and and my guess is
because Rhonda Santa said this in his
interview with uh Pierce Morgan he's
like I'm running against Joe Biden like
you are horrible at this dude you are so
[__] because what's gonna happen at
Waco this Saturday and tomorrow Donald
Trump's going to get on stage and he is
absolutely gonna cut [__] Rhonda
Santos off he's gonna cut him down he's
going to burn him down and piss on the
ashes and and his tiny little crowd is
gonna cheer it's gonna cheer and all
people around the country like yeah [__]
Rhonda Santos and it's gonna it's gonna
perpetuate and Rhonda Santos window as
small as it is is gonna get even smaller
faster and it's going to be beautiful I
don't know have you ever heard of them
a governor called Scott Walker you
remember that guy oh yeah I know Scott
Walker all too well because I've lived
in Wisconsin for a period let me ask you
what what is what office does Scott
Walker hold right now yeah which office
right what oh does he hold a public
office somewhere no why way to say he
was supposed to be a rising star in the
Republican Paul Walker is what happens
when you peek too early
Scott Walker is uh with also people who
know this Scott Walker also cheated when
he ran for school president
uh when he was at Marquette oh don't
don't don't tell me Republicans cheat to
win that's all [__]
are you saying they try to steal
elections are you serious let me see if
I can find the exact uh
but if you know the history of Scott
Walker Scott Walker was supposed to be
the president of the United States he
was the next best thing yeah he was
bringing Fox Khan over to Wisconsin he's
from the Midwest baby the Upper Midwest
he's the dude right he goes to Iowa
which is Southern Wisconsin yeah and he
[__] fails He Flops it's and it it is
over for him when he goes to Iowa and he
can't even he can't even make people
like him in Iowa listen Rhonda Rhonda
Santos is Scott Walker light he's not
he's not even up to the to the task of
how Scott Walker was going to propel his
campaign Rhonda said listen folks I know
it feels good to say he's going to get
in the race and I hope he does I want
him to be in the race it will be awesome
to watch Donald Trump go after him every
[__] day and Ronda Santos gets
shorter and shorter and shorter and
shorter and Destroy his political career
because that's what Donald Trump will do
for us with on the front of Ron Ron
desantos tiny D you know the pudding
meatball but here's the V three fingers
deep I just don't I don't see after this
weekend if Donald Trump attacks him on
stage I after the interview that he just
did with Pierce Morgan how people are
making fun of him and and it is a
guarantee guaran damn Tia that Donald
Trump is going to go on stage and make
make fun of that [__] why
wouldn't you right you know all right I
want him to yeah I want him too there
are going to be they're gonna be uh
there are going to be two assurances you
can get out of this uh Waco cult rally
right one is he's going to [__] and
moan about the four the four
investigations
and pending indictments right probably
only incriminating himself even further
my talk he's going to talk about how
there were two perfect phone calls which
we learned
because you also called the speaker
right so there are three perfect phone
calls that he made because first when he
was like oh look it was a perfect phone
call then it was too perfect phone calls
which by the way nobody ever revealed he
revealed it for us right wait two phone
calls right and then recently we found
out from the Georgia Fulton County
investigation that it's now three phone
calls at least there could be more
so not only that and then you've got
Stormy Daniels which is that one that's
looming over him right now
freaking out about right and then you've
got Jack Smith coming after him for Jan
six and also Mar-A-Lago and Mar-A-Lago
seems to be really picking up speed as
we now one of the people that are on our
list for bonehead this week now has to
testify and hand over all of the
recordings and the notes that will most
likely reveal that Donald Trump knew
that he was lying intentionally lying
and that his his uh his legal counsel
also knew about this as well
well and and the other point that I was
the third prong here that is going to
happen this weekend is because they're
doing it in Waco and they're supposed to
be these undertones right I mean that's
what he's trying to he's he's trying to
bring us back to the early 90s when this
extremist movement on the right was
taking rise they were bombing I don't
know government buildings in Oklahoma
um you know all these things and
um he so he's he has those undertones of
people worried about that but I'm like
actually this is going to prove that
that's all [__] but that's all [__]
that D that he does not have the
following that you think he has it is
going to be the same old geriatric
people in the Trump costumes that show
up the cult members the professional
wrestling uh types that are gonna show
up there's gonna be you know dozens of
them that show up down there in Waco and
I hope the I hope the real media is
there because it is Waco and the
significance of it and I hope they're
way in the back and they show how many
people are not there
and they and and I hope I don't know is
Walter going is good liars going I'm
sure they are
um but if somebody's going down there
and sticking microphones in front of
these people's faces and knowing that
that these these folks that are going to
these rallies are just boneheads they're
just but it's just professional
wrestling is all it is we're at the
intersection of WrestleMania real life
and that's the main event but the thing
that is going to hurt Donald Trump the
most is when he gets on stage and he
admits to the crimes and the thing
that's going to hurt the Republican
Party the most is when he goes on stage
and he destroys Ron Ron tiny D's career
this weekend because he's gonna do I
mean because we have to look at what's
going to happen here right he gets
indicted well first off he attacks Ron
DeSantis right he pushes this guy into
being a [__] nobody right he was a
nobody before and admittedly Donald
Trump made him a somebody and now
because he's trying to be Trump 2.0 or
Trump Jr or whatever I know Don Jr is
probably having a little bit of an ego
crisis right now but you know he's
really trying to be Donald Trump Jr in
the sense that he's you know he's got
the same hand movements if you look at
the Pierce Morgan tape he literally
honest to God you could cut out the face
and you look at the lower body it looks
like they're both [__] wearing
diapers I swear to God I swear to God
you look at the if you cut it off
because I'm going to end up doing a what
was that on this but um you look at the
bottom I was watching the interview
yesterday and I was like man it's
similar in the sense that they both
had interviews with Pierce Morgan before
but when you look at the their posture I
was like what the [__] is what is so
saggy down there and I swear they're
both wearing diapers and both of the
interviews they do Donald Trump and
Rhonda santis so when you look at this
you think wait wait do you think Rhonda
Santos is trying to copy him by wearing
a diaper oh 100 100 you know that's the
thing about the interview a little bit
that I thought was funny the clips that
I seen and what let's talk about the
interview before we go to bonehead yeah
I got another clip so pull some clips
that you want to show of that of the
Pierce Morgan put the links there
um because I got another video I want to
show you of of a guy who's certainly
going to show up at Waco you know one of
these one of these tough guys I'm going
to show you is it is it JFK Jr uh well
he might be there I mean I don't know it
depends on uh it depends on if he's
coming back to life or not but um um
what the [__] is I gonna say God damn I
got off oh um
yeah we're going to talk about Rhonda
Santos well let me just show you this
clip let me just show you this clip this
is the guy that is going to show up in
Waco that's going to cause all kinds of
trouble he's a real tough guy here I'm
telling you this oh man this is a
typical oh typical Trump have you ever
watched have you watched the full
interview uh I know I was debating I was
like
I don't know if I should [__] on this
kid more but I kind of want to
like I want to do like a whole episode
on this kid's alleged
alleged fears that he had in this
classroom because I'll I'll give you
more info once we play this clip
okay okay well let me play the clip yeah
yeah what people are saying what it
looks like a dick behind me okay hang on
hang on I gotta are you oh oh this looks
like a dick let's hear this Shadow this
Shadow right here what shadow you see it
up here on the on the corner oh oh yeah
yeah by U.S that's the bull that's the
bullhorn yeah I got a big [__] up here
oh you people your minds are in the
[__] gutter in the chat man look at
that I mean it kind of does [__] like
now that I see it I can't right now you
can't unsee the car up there right okay
well I'll adjust that later yeah or I'll
leave it either way for the chat [__]
you guys you know what they're mad at me
here's here's the the chat's mad at me
The tyt Sims in the chat the people who
like Jake over there at dyd they're mad
at me because we're gonna go after Jank
here oh I got some stuff on him too I
know I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
[__] I'm gonna bury this thing up
here in the corner I'm gonna bury it
deep down inside
tyt here in a minute so you [__] you
people in the goddamn chat your mind is
always in the goddamn gutter okay let's
let's get back to business here would
you stop thinking about Cox in the chat
okay I know it's Friday and you're
excited for the weekend but Jesus I just
I was just my mine was on the whole like
you know yeah well I I pointed out to
you and you're like yeah there's a dick
yeah no it's not only that but it's also
like you know the for everyone who can't
see here here's yeah you look up there
let's move on we'll talk about right up
right up right up here yeah right up
there yeah right yeah right just figure
it out there's I'll finger my uh you
[__] you creep tense okay um cretins
Creek well
say it Okay let's listen to this tough
guy here he's a real tough guy he looks
like a tough guy someone said it looks
like Kyle Rittenhouse and Nick Adams
[__] and had a baby yeah
it looks like it looks like that let's
listen to him how tough he is though
let's see what's about what happened
that day that prompted your reaction
so Stella I'm over at this uh great
School in Boca Raton called uh Lynn
University
um and what happened in class on Monday
is something I'm never gonna forget
because I stood up for my transmission
for college kids across the country wow
kids every single is he gonna tell us he
beat some people he beat some liberals
up because say I stood up for all the
gosh because he's tough guy what's is
that what he did did he uh
like if there was a spectrum of things
you could do and on one end it was like
uh be violent and beat someone up and
the other end was be a [__] ass [__]
uh I think you'll find that he's on the
[__] ass [__] side okay well let's
listen let's hear let's hear if you're
correct the school across the country
and I'm standing there in class and they
put this awful cartoon image of the
former president up on the screen oh my
God and when I did that uh as you saw in
that video my classmates begin to uh
laugh at me and then days later after I
posted this to a tick tock I had to
actually make my account private because
oh no oh my God some terrible uh threats
uh people telling me that I should go
end my own life and I doubt nobody said
that I should hope that I don't run into
them on campus nobody said that and the
school's doing a great job of helping me
uh stay safe right now to thank them but
it sounds like it needs a safe space and
here's here's the shot here's the video
yeah well I mean
was Senator that he voted against blacks
did you know that I bet you didn't know
that because you only believe in one
thing
have a good class
have a good class here's a picture of
this guy with Donald Trump
they look like quite a pair don't they
yeah they or something uh so here's
here's what happened right so this kid's
in class and they're going through it's
a
it was a uh history of a history of
something class so it was talking about
presidential leaders right and it was
bringing up the characteristics that
each of these leaders had and they
brought up Trump and he said the way he
described it was Trump was a pig and he
was in the [__] the the lock and uh
the [__] uh oh my God the lock
Stables right
yeah I don't know I'm looking at the jet
ear yeah Hunter's hog is in here I'm
honored to be on Tony's wall you people
talking about dicks in the jet we're
trying listen we're trying to break down
a goddamn video here we're trying to do
a show and you keep talking about the
dick on my wall I'm gonna leave it there
actually you know what I might go this
afternoon and get me a big old fat dildo
and just put it right up there you
[__] weirdos If You're Gonna Keep in
the chat so anyways what were you asking
I'm sorry I'm distracted sorry okay I'm
distracted by Hunter's hog like the
House Republicans are I mean honestly
who wouldn't be
uh so uh his he was in the stocks right
the pillory which is the instrument that
you put your head and your hands in
according to this kid Donald Trump was a
cartoon pig in the stocks right so he
had no he had his head and His Hands
through the stocks now
the the woman on oan was like well why
didn't you I noticed that you filmed it
the way that you did it was like towards
you and you didn't film the class he
goes because I feared for my life
he goes there were 30 students in the
classroom and I was afraid that if I
filmed it they would attack me oh my God
30 and he goes the third he goes uh when
you look he's like 30 to one that's not
really fair odds is it
oh my God Jesus Christ okay this kid is
playing victim and I told Tony last
night in a text I was like these people
these Republicans want so desperately to
be oppressed right to oppress that they
will make something up to be like oh my
life was threatened people said they
better not see me on campus or I heard
them nobody's [__] saying that they
laughed at him right because he was he
they laughed at him because he was
triggered by a cartoon because it's
funny that you claim to be tough guys
and he's Mr tough president and all this
[__] right and you guys claim that you
know he he appears in superhero costumes
and [__] and he's so badass and he's a
tough guy he'll take down any [__]
dictator anywhere and he's the he's the
president that'll get us out of work
because he's a badass and then you can't
take that he that there's a political
cartoon of him yeah you [__] you
goddamn [__] ass and he was like he's
like look if there was any other
president Barack Obama or or Joe Biden I
would say the same
I highly doubt that
but I will say this the fact that he's
like oh man the students were gonna beat
me up in class no they [__] weren't
and then he made a claim that the
teacher told him never to come back in
class again which I highly doubt that
happened either
the kid made a fool of himself because
he decided to stand up and say hey can
we not do this as unfair to President
Biden or president Trump because he also
said I've met the guy he's a really nice
guy I've met him at the in in Florida
I've met him at the golf resort I met
him in New Jersey I've had dinner with
him he's a really nice guy honestly just
like the dick in the back you know just
like the USA dick up here on my wall the
dick Shadow just the just the small just
a small one yeah well
oh my God yeah this show is is uh is
plummeting into uh I we've gone into and
I think I think recep is right about you
I think seven is right about right and
he's definitely right about the viewers
you [__] but I'll say this the full
interview with this kid and that's
always like oh man
did he do a media circuit and this was
just the only one was the one that Ron
could he might have done another one but
I definitely watched the interview that
he had in oan the full interview
where he whines and complains about the
fact that like students laughed at him
but what he doesn't include in here is
that he also says that the students
threatened to kill him and threatened to
hurt him
to which I'm like no one no one is
threatening to hurt you you already made
a [__] idiot of yourself by standing
up to defend I mean it might be wait it
might be right Wingers that are yeah I
couldn't hurt him because he looks like
such a [__] wimp it could be and
could be but I can tell you right now
there's no reason there would be no
reason that anyone would threaten this
kid when he just stood up and said uh
can you take this down can you can you
take this down this isn't this isn't
right can you not can you not have a a a
a political cartoon of trump as a pig
livestocks and they laughed at him and
then he continued doing he's like all
right well have a nice class probably
right through that show they laughed at
him the teacher didn't no the teacher
never told him
that he should never come back to class
and the students definitely did not
[__] threaten him and say oh good
luck on campus I hope I don't see you
like what the [__] are you talking about
what a [__] what a [__] oh my God and
we're supposed to believe these are the
tough guys get the [__] out of here well
we have we have a few tough guys what is
this oh phallic Fridays
rice you
you [__] people are obsessed with
dick
why are you obsessed with dick we're not
getting enough clearly I guess so I mean
I've got it right up here on the screen
all the time
the dick shadow
and he's just hogging the tension yeah
you [__] you [__] I'm getting a
dildo and I'm budding behind me I'm
gonna go buy the biggest [__] [__] I
can find yeah what are those you got to
get one of those like that stick you
know she's got like it like you stick it
right maybe I'll make a video you should
do it at the beginning of the show at
the beginning of the show be like okay
check me out and then you
maybe I can hang it on like my wall from
up here so it so it hangs you know what
I mean I don't know if you could you
could we could make it how much how much
well we could make a segment yeah where
it's a question and because and we we
have basically the length of time to
make an argument is all based on how
long the dildo sticks on the ceiling
all right quick it's like the it's like
the the countdown clock is what you're
saying yeah exactly you don't know how
long it's gonna be it could be for 10
seconds what would you call it the dick
stick
you know um let's see what would you
call it you gotta have a name for it
then we'd have that music for it
you know that would be the maybe it's
called don't be a dick don't be a dick
sticky Dicky
another one sticky Dicky you [__]
people I tell you one you're the best
audience this is why you're the best
audience in the world someone's
suggesting butt plugs now see wait you
want you want all these sex toys behind
me is that what you want you know it's
funny because
um when Don Jr used to do his uh
you know his videos that he did Big Dick
Energy yeah
uh remember when he used to do this
video and he has that big glass dildo up
behind him yeah he still has it he still
has it it's like a big glass dildo bong
or some [__] I don't know I was always
wondering for whatever I don't know
right now I don't know I don't know who
he uses his honor if he uses on himself
or what but it looks interesting maybe
or you know what actually why don't we
do this yeah instead of it instead of
you buying it people should you should
make an Amazon wish list
and then people should buy it and then
you and then basically you then then we
just add a collection so by the end of
the time it'd just be a bunch of like
yeah [__] dildos randomly in the back
all over all over I'll throw some on the
wall
this is a speaker but just imagine you
know having just one off on the side
talking I don't I don't I don't know
folks I don't know if Gabe Sanchez has
been smoking something this morning or
what's going on but he's all in for the
um he's on with you I think the people
in the chat are totally fine for the
dick shadow
um
you people with your it's hard it's hard
to to get out from that shadow once it's
there you know right right once you see
the dick Shadow it's hard to unsee it
but it's just it's the [__] megaphone
back there folks is its own yeah I mean
we don't know who knows we'll never know
and starting to [__] tell I guess I
don't know I don't know all right we got
it we gotta do bone end of the week
Jesus Christ not [__] of the week we
gotta do bone end of the week so stick
around
we'll be back with you cretins right
after this don't go anywhere bone of the
week as soon as we come back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
you sick perverted [__]
Jesus Christ
some suggestions in the chances
[Music]
because we are in bonehead of the week
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week okay once once let's get back to
the chat here hang on let me pull some
of this uh beat the dick
oh that's actually pretty good that's
actually good pretty good that's a good
one beat the dick and Cox our [__] from
Heaven
let's see another one was uh someone
said wall bangers I don't see that one
here wall bangers that's a good one
oh man penis a fortune
oh [__]
you people you people this is why hey
there you go Steve says boner of the
week instead of bonehead owner of the
week
booner
today is boner of the weeks and she
pointed out the uh the [__] Shadow
Taco penis that's another good one
I mean we could just make one where it's
a dick and then it's the face of
that could be it could be
you [__] people we got bone end of
the week I promise we're gonna do it
here we're gonna be over time today
because um we got a lot to talk about
look everyone in the chat has filthy
filthy minds and that's really fun
that's what we like about you to be
going on us you're able to be yourself
that's right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast we don't give a [__] and the
main reason why is because YouTube
refuses to give us back our monetization
I think it's because of you [__]
though in the chat it feels like it now
it feels like it now they're like Jesus
Christ
what's with this chat over here on this
guy's show no I'm just kidding it's not
you it's me yeah uh as George Cassandra
would say it's not you it's me oh boy
what we got a lot to talk about I I
swear I swear I'm gonna show you why why
I keep saying what I say about Jank
younger and tyt I swear I'm gonna do it
I told you I was going to wait till the
end which I probably will just to have
you guys hang around what are you are
you changing [__] in there uh I I had a
misspelling
I sent you that video the other day the
the PornHub one and at the end it's
Donald Trump I'm Gonna Come
I'm gonna come and it's hilarious it's
one of the best pieces of tape of him
speaking of Donald Trump we got to get
the bone of the week everybody let's
start the music
[Music]
[Applause]
boner of the week oh wait bonehead of
the week oh right different segment
difference
maybe maybe we'll maybe we'll go do
boner of the week over on
[Music]
patreoner of the week we're getting real
up close and personal tonight
okay back away from the microphone you
you've created okay
um so we've got we got a few boners on
bone end of the week this week we got
Donald Trump of course
he definitely wins I mean Jesus Christ
he's a [__] Landslide right oh my god
um Evan Corcoran
Evan Corcoran his his name kind of
sounds like Cocker and people have been
calling Cochran on the media have you
noticed that and usually I mispronounce
people's names so maybe I'll go with
Evan Cochran since uh we're on the Dick
Shadow today and then Jank Unger Jank
under Jake eager is it I don't know
I think it's Jake ooger right there
yeah
I used to watch Jake when he was on
MSNBC and he was a clownman he's a clown
now and I'm going to tell you why it's
all a bit and it's all sticking and some
of you guys are falling for it it's
funny that you're falling for it I'm
gonna show you why you're I'm going to
show you how he's it's a stick man it's
all [__] it's it's funny it's funny
that you think he's like oh yeah he's
for Bernie and all this [__] and blah
blah blah yakity schmankity but I'm
going to show you a tape from 11 years
ago
now you guys can like what the [__] okay
especially when you put in the context
of time the time now
and what they were trying to do 11 years
ago the Republicans that is and and what
led up to Donald Trump and trumpism in
this country and and I'm gonna show you
why trumpism caught on and why it's not
all the rights fault it's because we
took our Eye Off the Ball us liberals
took our eye out the ball and started to
cheerlead authoritarianism
um even from the left because it had
authoritarianism doesn't isn't right or
left and I don't know if you guys know
that but authoritarianism can be can be
left or right authoritarian is an
authoritarianism go look the word up you
can go look up the history on
authoritarianism and right-wing
authoritarianism and a left-wing
authoritarianism and I'm telling you I'm
telling you I'm telling you when I show
you this just this little part of an
interview that he did 11 years ago and
you see this it it's gonna probably
change your mind you're gonna know what
I'm [__] talking about when I when I
say stop listening to tyt now help I
listen and maybe I should do let's just
do let's just do Jank first that's gonna
wait till the end of doing but now let's
just do him first [__] it we're here
okay
the reason why I tell you that tyt is
[__] is because they have a defeatist
attitude they don't like the Democrats
they attack the Democrats now you would
say Tony is isn't it okay to attack
Democrats yeah sure it's okay to attack
Democrats that's fine but when you're
using you're using right wing when
you're using right-wing arguments
against the left that are untrue and
just [__] stupid and you're using
that to convince people not to go vote
you are not for democracy you were not a
pro-democracy uh part of the Coalition
because everyone it says why do you
attack tyt they attack the left I'm
attacking the left when I attack tyt
pluck your head out of your ass okay
what they're doing from the left is
trying to convince people not to vote
for the left and not to go vote which
only is suppressing our own vote I hear
this [__] all the time when they're like
oh these these Democrats on the hill
keep sending me emails wanting money for
me yeah yeah because we got we have to
win elections what do you think this
[__] is [__] free yeah do you think
this [__] is free listen if you don't
want fundraising emails don't open them
don't open them
reply back to not being on the text
chain okay you don't have to get the
[__] fundraising emails if you don't
want them you don't have to now you
should if you got a few bucks
donate to protemocracy co-pay
pro-democracy campaigns you should be
doing that if you can if you can
but but this idea that somehow the
Democrats are the same as the
Republicans I've been saying this over
and over and over and over and over
again you are full of [__] [__]
is is there [__] that Democrats could do
better you goddamn right we're trying to
fix that we're trying to fix that but
there's only one party in this country
who is concerned with democracy at all
and it is the Democratic party until the
Republican Party comes back to the table
of democracy they are the threat to it
because they are trying to use our
democracy to get rid of it I don't know
if you've been paying attention to what
they've been doing in these State houses
but they're trying to legislate our
fellow countrymen out of existence
because of who they are or how they
[__] dress up at a goddamn
performance
they're taking away women's bodily
autonomy they're [__] they're [__]
dumping weapons of war on our streets
folks I don't know if you're paying
attention or not to what kind of fascist
State Rhonda santis wants and what he's
trying to do down in Florida by Banning
books Banning Banning teachers for all
intents and purposes and banning words
they're scared of words Jesus Christ he
tried to ban Disney because they were
against the don't say gay Bill he didn't
he wasn't successful at it and and he's
still trying to act like he did
something with Disney it's it's
absolutely [__] ridiculous that
anyone thinks that both signs are the
same and that's the [__] they say on tyt
they say it all the time they've been
saying it it's always been that
[__] stick always this isn't
something new that I'm making up about
them I again I'm gonna show you a little
[__] clip of Jank Unger
I'm putting an n in it aren't I Unger
yeah it's it's you y g u r there's an n
in it I don't give a [__] all right
that's what I'm saying I'm saying his
first name correctly I could say his his
first name wrong I mean it ain't you
know
anyways the point is this is that if
you're mad if you're mad that I go after
tyt then you're mad for the reasons that
I go after tyt not that I'm just going
after them because you act like I've
been I've been attacking tyt and Jank
for a while but when I show you how why
he's on bonehead when I show you why is
it can you pull uh her tweet up because
I know she's she's the DM right yeah is
that what you made so let's let's just
let's just get into this [__] here
um there was something that triggered
his bone-headed move and it was uh
what's her name here let me pull it up
she's the DM today Anna
Anna you guys have seen this uh what's
funny is she has this viral video out
there of her talking about the Bible and
religion and you can't just keep your
[__] religion out of my [__] space
you can believe what you want to believe
that that doesn't mean I have to believe
and it's a great clip of Anna it's a
viral clip it's got millions of views
people repost it all the time it's a
great clip great little sound bite
for Liberty meaning I have the Liberty
to have my religion you have the Liberty
to have your religion but you can't
force yours on me and I can't force
yours on you
but here's a tweet she sent out right
this is I believe this is in contrary or
opposite of that idea okay here let me
show you this
um and this is what sparked the whole
debate and this is why he's trending is
because of this tweet that she put out
and the reason why is because not only
did she put this tweet out he [__]
came in and fiercely defended it which I
think the Tweet alone you know whatever
this is her opinion uh and and it's and
it's his opinion too I don't give a [__]
they can yell it from the rooftops for
all I care I don't give a [__] what I'm
saying is is you people thinking that
I'm attacking him because I'm just
trying to create a feud someone said
that [__] this morning I'm trying to
create a few doesn't exist listen I'm
trying to tell you what's bad for
democracy that's what I'm trying to
[__] tell you I'm trying to tell you
where the authoritarians and the and the
[__] fascists are gonna move in and
what they're gonna use against us the
pro-democracy Coalition the people want
to keep our [__] Liberty in this
country and he here she is here's what
she says I am a woman great great and as
a woman I'm happy that she identifies as
a woman fantastic that's great I I I am
nothing instead please don't ever refer
to me as a person with a uterus a
birthing person or a person who
menstruates listen I doubt anyone has
ever walked up to her and said any one
of those things to her face this is
[__] dumb what she's talking about
and out I'm telling you
hey hey you people out there that love
tyt and hate when I knock them here's
what they're doing they're getting on
the anti-woke train
is what they're doing here folks they're
testing out the waters they're testing
out the Waters of the anti-woke train
with this trans [__] stuff that that
the right keeps going after like um
what's that Nazi rag daily wire with
Matt Walsh and that [__] [__] bag
Michael Knowles they're trying that out
on you okay that's what they're doing
they're floating this [__] and trying it
out on you and I don't care what kind of
Ally they are you can [__] hate on me
all you want this is what they're doing
it's a [__] that they do I'm gonna prove
it to you and they're trying it out on
you how do you how do people not realize
how degrading this is what are you
talking about
someone who who wants to be called a
person with a uterus would not be would
not be offended by that Jesus Christ
people are called manga all the time and
they're proud of it they're called Ultra
Maga and they're [__] proud of it
folks what are you talking about
you could support the transgender
Community without doing this [__]
see you see that thin veil there that
she's draping over
listen I am not against her wanting to
be called a woman but no one I guarantee
you and maybe she could prove it to me
by having a video or something or maybe
a lot of comments that are thrown her
way of calling her a person with a
uterus calling her a birthing person or
a person who menstruates because frankly
frankly I think this is ridiculous and
again he goes all in on it is this that
what's this next to it you sent me is
this the one where he did this no this
is the thread that breaks it down but
there's another one that uh the third
one is the one where he defends it right
and again I I know how it's being
presented
um
what the [__]
what I got logged out of Twitter that's
[__] weird man that's [__] weird
elon's [__] with me here's here
that's crazy no I I got the Tweeter all
right
um Anna Anna and and Jank here uh
because Jake chimed in I'm gonna show
you that know exactly what they're doing
this is a trial balloon for so-called
progressives and liberals to see if
they're okay with transphobia they're
trying to see how far they can go with
this stuff Anna using these terms with
the stain as if someone's been harming
harmed is Peak Turf think [__] the Young
Turk turfs I love it young turfs
um but it's the truth what I mean what
do you what do you want other than what
it is on its face right am I wrong about
this or am I just crazy that I'm reading
it this way they did log me out what the
[__] there now I'm logged back in that's
[__] weird is it because of the link
you sent me hang on a second let me
double check this
that's weird oh what's going on it's the
Deep State yeah it's the Deep State it's
when I use your links here in the chat
and it's all right that's right it
doesn't matter
all right here's his tweet defending her
this is the bone because we were trying
to determine whether it should be her on
the bonehead or him on the bonehead and
I asked Gabe Sanchez I said look is it
more boneheaded what she said or more
boneheaded that he defended it after she
said it and we determined that it was
probably more bone-headed that he
defended it here's his defense if you
think I'm gonna tell my female co-host
what she can call herself or what word
she's allowed to use your nuts I agree
with that I agree with that do you see
how he's doing it though do you see it
do you see it and you don't know me at
all we do something radical at tyt we
let everyone have their own opinion I
know it's novel concept the media listen
yours what you're saying exact opposite
of what she said it's the exact opposite
if someone else can have the opinion of
a person with a uterus then that's their
[__] opinion that's their [__]
Liberty these people these people have
been doing this stick for a long time
and this stick is is that both sides are
the same that's what it is and they're
saying they're trying they're trying out
an anti-wokism campaign because folks
honestly the reason why the right's been
doing this anti-wokism thing is because
it makes a lot of money I don't know if
you know that I I mean I mean we could
we could make so much more money here on
this show if I just went oh wokeism and
you're you're against me you're trying
to cancel us and oh anti-woke this and
anti-woke that if I did that [__] I
would make someone much more money oh my
God it would be glorious it'd just be
cash flowing in all over the place what
do you think they're doing what do you
think they're doing and you people who
come after you say oh Tony I can't
believe you attacked tyt I can't believe
you do this it's this is the reason why
because Jake has always always railed
against the [__] corporate media and
corporate Democrats that's what he calls
it and and you people out there like oh
you don't know anything about tyt you
don't watch it listen I was watching
Jake when when he did his tryout on
MSNBC years ago
when he was trying to move from the tyt
to the corporate media the people that
he [__] says he hates so don't tell
me what I know and what I don't know
um what's this tweet here that you're
sending me it's it well it was a tweet
from yesterday but it's it's this stiff
okay so for anyone who you know Tony and
I have talked about this before uh tyt
has a tendency to be uh they have a big
platform but they have a tendency to be
defeatist right and it's an ultimatum
type of type of persona that they have
it's either it's got to be this way or
it's nothing at all and this is another
thing right here this is falling into
the trap now I don't obviously nobody
knows what Alvin Bragg knows other than
his team and the grand jury
so when people speculate to be like oh
there's no case or is this or that we
don't really know we could [__] talk
till we turn blue right like we don't
know exactly what is being presented to
the case only those who are privy to who
have been interviewed right not the
people who not the interviewees but the
people have been interviewed that have
watched them right
the jury prosecution the Manhattan DA's
office those people know so when when
people go out and say well you know
there's no case or it's this or that
like again we have no idea until we see
an indictment right and we see what
those charges are because it could be
for the very thing that everyone assumes
but it also could be for something
totally unrelated or rather it is
related but nobody knew about and that's
the reason Alvin Bragg brought it back
so Jank here is saying like it turns out
Alvin Bragg might not charge Trump after
all this is in I'm assuming in response
to a whole day this is a whole day later
this is last night that he that he
responded to a second delay right
because they're going to convene on
Monday and then we'll see how it happens
next week but Jake here is saying it
turns out Alvin Bragg might not charge
Trump after all we told you these
prosecutors are elected Democrats which
means they're scared to death of
Republicans and love the elites which
means there are very little chance they
would take on a former Republican
president
I don't think that's true but also the
Assumption before anyone knows anything
right
is that this guy goes we told you so
even from the get-go Jake and the team
were saying there's nothing here this is
a dumb thing uh he's not gonna charge
him blah blah blah and now trying to be
like see I was right but here's the
thing
we don't know yet because they haven't
come back with a grand jury because they
haven't been allowed uh they they were
delayed two days right so they haven't
convened which will be on Monday in
another three days
so Jank and the rest of the team being
like
this is what we told you
defeatist this same approach the same
the same mentality they had during the
midterms
it was they're gonna lose Democrats or
you know they have to change it right
game you just have to do that it's going
to be a red wave that's what they said
and what we saw was yes Democrats lost
their their advantage position in the
house but the Assumption was it was
going to be 20 to 30 seats that the
Democrats were going to lose by and they
only lost by a handful of seats when you
actually look at the numbers
so it just Falls in line with the same
thing that Jake and them do all the time
which is like ah it's never gonna work
out Jesus Christ man have a little bit
of Faith here right you don't know just
as well as I don't know when Tony
doesn't know there's other [__] that's
going up on the scenes that no one is
privy to right so everyone's assumption
on this is like oh look I knew it these
[__] Democrats they cut they weren't
gonna they weren't gonna go after him
yep and that's exactly what they're
doing in Federal in a federal court
today when the grand jury is hearing
testimony from Donald Trump's attorney
on a crime fraud exemption right this is
all [__] stupid [__] yes yes guess
what guess what guess what Jack Smith is
Gabe Sanchez guess what he is there's a
there's a Democrat elected president he
nominated listen to this he nominated an
attorney general who's who who is uh
nominated by a Democrat right um his
name's uh mayor Garland the Democrats in
the Senate confirmed that nomination did
you know that the electric corporate
Democrats confirmed the nomination and
then and then what happened was is
Merrick Garland appointed Jack Smith and
today so he must be some kind of elected
prosecutor Democrat left-wing lunatic
listen Jank is doing what right-wingers
do and and this this thing that him and
Anna did they toyed with this for last
or was it two days ago or yesterday that
they toyed with this anti-wokism thing
with this woman as if someone came up to
her and called her uh two two days ago
which again I want to be clearer too I
want to be clear here too I don't give a
[__] if if tyt exists I'm not saying
Bantam or cancel them or whatever I'm
just saying when you listen to him I'm
gonna show you what the [__] you're
listening to this is um I'm gonna show
it to you here let me see if I can pull
this um
that's a YouTube video I'm saying I
gotta find the timestamp I think did I
send it to you this morning yeah you
said I did okay let me see if I can find
this link
um this this is a YouTube video and it's
a um
what it is is it is a broadcast
from 11 years ago on Democracy Now now I
I told you in the beginning that
um Jake was on MSNBC he had a show on
MSNBC it was kind of like a tryout show
um is what it is that's how that's how a
lot of times the corporate media works
is they have a tryout and you go and you
have a show and and you get to be a host
for a while and then if you're really
good at it and you build an audience
then you get another show now he left
MSNBC the circumstances are really no
one knows exactly what happens because
he has one story MSNBC the the the the
the bosses that be at the time had a
different story right they had a
different story but I want to show you
now I also I also want to say that the
the media was much different in reacting
to the news at the time because 2016
election hadn't happened yet and Donald
Trump had not been president our media
has changed how they react to stuff they
still are stuck in this Trump Loop and
I'm you guys know that I'm [__] I'm
just as much of a Critic as the
corporate media I don't call it that
because I think that's dumb I call it
the mainstream media because that's what
it is it's mainstream they're the media
they're the Press I'm not the Press I
don't have a [__] press press and I
have credentials I'm a commentator I'm
here to entertain you and tell you what
the [__] I think and most of you listen
to what I think whether you love it or
hate it I don't give a [__] my a lot of
you might hate what he says here in this
interview
it's 11 years ago and this is the
context they're asking about the
situation where where he left MSNBC but
listen to what he says about Barack
Obama okay listen to this this is and I
don't give a [__] if someone calls
Barack Obama this I'm just telling you
the stick he's been doing this whole
time
and it's always been a stick it always
has been listen
well there's no question that I was by
far the least supportive of the Obama
Administration I saw your last segment
and I couldn't agree more with your
guests I think President Obama is
clearly you know a republican uh did I
did I hear that right did I hear what
what did he just say Gabe Sanchez
play it again should I play it again
yeah let's play it again let's see if um
let's see if I can back that up just a
bit here oh that's too far right there
Okay let's listen to what he says again
about about Obama and see if our
audience or anyone out there in a
pro-democracy coalition even if you hate
some stuff that Obama did let's see if
you agree with this statement your last
segment and I couldn't agree more with
your guests I think uh President Obama
well
yeah
I'm not [__] used to YouTube I guess
God damn
it hang on a second hang on a second and
we're having technical difficulties here
this is a moment where I go what was
that what yeah what was that what was
that but the fact that I mean here the
fact that here I got it I got I got it I
got it here all right for the least
supportive of the Obama Administration I
saw your last segment and I couldn't
agree more with your guests I think uh
President Obama is clearly you know a
republican uh
Barack Obama what was that now again you
may have a lot of disagreements with
Obama you may not think Obama went left
enough right you may you may think that
he he was some kind of [__] right
wing far-right Nazi plan right you may
think that but that's all [__] what
he just said that Barack Obama is
definitely 100
unequivocally a republican listen folks
this is the guy that you go over and you
listen to it tyt and some of the [__] he
says makes sense of course it does some
of the [__] I say doesn't make any sense
okay I get it I get it
but you got to know where he starts from
and he's starting from this point
and that is why he's not good for
democracy and he is not a soldier for
the pro-democracy Coalition folks he
wants to destroy our democracy just like
the right does and he's trying and him
and Anna the reason why they're on the
bonehead this week I mean here's the
real reason why is because what they're
trying to do what they're trying to do
is use this wokism [__] to do it and
they're just doing it from the left
instead of from the right because it
happens all the time this oh there's
cancer culture there's a ton of [__]
comedians out there that are quote
left-wing that are on this anti-woope
thing because they're getting canceled
because the [__] they're saying stop
saying it then if you don't like people
judging you if you don't want people to
[__] come at you don't say it don't
say it and also the thing is it's not
just don't say it but if you know like
if you know there's a history of
somebody saying something and you say oh
well if I say this thing people are
probably going to come after me right
they're probably going to get mad at
what I say say you know that based on
you know
history right if you were to say oh my
Republican counterparts they got
canceled because they said this thing
don't [__] say it if you know what's
going to happen you know the
consequences of your action then don't
take that action if you do not want the
consequence right because you know
what's going to happen it's not like you
are totally just blindsided you didn't
know what was going to happen you're
like oh well I just made this simple
mistake no no you've seen again and
again and again people who say racist
bigoted transphobic homophobic just
outright terrible things
and when you say those or when other
people have said it there have been
repercussions or Consequences whether
it's people that have come at backlash
because they said you know this or that
they've they've uh you know boycotted
their business they've done this or
whatever it might be you know what will
happen because you've seen it happen
before
and so when these people go no you know
what I'm going to say it and then when
they get consequences for it they go oh
what guys that's not fair I know this is
cancel culture no no you can't play dumb
you knew it was gonna happen and you did
it anyway because you want to feel
oppressed well and I think again some
people are saying it's about the money
in the chat and I said that earlier it's
absolutely about the money it's
absolutely about the money because they
there is a ton of money right now on the
right wing when you're attacking wokism
like that's the whole stick I don't know
I don't know if we played in enough
clips for you or not but Fox News is
living off the word folk wokism right
now oan Newsmax all these right wing
hints that's all they have deep State
and wokism that's all they have and it
makes no sense I mean even the the
[__] [__] who wrote the book on
wokism couldn't Define it on a
right-wing show
when she was asked simply what does that
mean and I know there was a softball
pitch that's right I know what they're
doing here I know what they're doing I'm
on to them I can smell I can smell I can
smell them taking on right-wing talking
points just like they do around
elections around the Red Wave and they
bought into that [__] I can sense
they're buying into the anti-wokism
stuff and they think it's going to be
profitable well I'm gonna call them out
for it I here's what I'm gonna do all
you tyt steps I'm gonna call the left
Jank and Anna and tyt out on their
[__] so just know when you come here
on the Tony Michaels podcast and Bone
end of the week we call out the left we
call out the left baby
oh [__] yeah [__] him and [__] her
that's what I say [__] them uh you know
that's just I mean that's I mean it's
just it's it's just something where like
you hear people complain like oh you
guys only go after the right I mean yeah
because a lot of the time the right is
[__] dumb and they say dumb [__] but
we will go after people on the left when
you're attacking our own in the sense of
like
if you're attacking a community and
trying to be subtle about it and trying
to be coy and be like Oh I'm a woman and
I'm not that dude shut the [__] up man
like you can't play this you can't play
this like well I'm gonna be critical
here and I'm gonna no no no
you're just being terrible right and
we're gonna call people out like that
and and the idea that if anyone comes in
here from the right it's like oh well
you don't call people on the left out
yes we do [__] especially when
you're saying right wing talking points
yes you're not helping you're not
helping us you're helping them right
when you say right wing talking points
if you're doing it for money because you
think it's profitable for you and your
little your little media your
Independent Media thing to say anti-woke
step and to float anti-woke to see if
you can get your audience uh on board
with the anti-woke stuff so you can
continue this stupid ass stupid ass
right wing talking point which that's
what it is wokism and anyone who says
the word woke when they're talking about
woke they're they're they're dumb as
[__] they don't know what woke is number
one because they just don't know and and
two they're using it especially in
Independent Media they're using it for
[__] profit when it's the enemy when
it's the enemy they're doing it for
probably trust me trust me we could do
that stick here I could do that stick
you don't think a white dude with a
beard like me wears a red at could do
the anti-woke I could do an anti-woke
thing and make a lot of [__] [__] I
can flip on a dime and pretend to be a
right winger make all kinds of money you
fools people people have said that I
should do it people have accused me that
I'll do it one day do you think that's
true I don't know probably not going to
be true I seem like I'm pretty
passionate about my beliefs for on
Democracy it just I don't know it feels
like it to me probably and then it's
genuine where I come from but you know
that's just just a feeling I get for
myself I guess maybe you guys should
judge me on that speaking of the judging
people
um we got a cuck
speaking of right-wing Talking Heads
who who float this [__] listen listen
when Nick Fuentes and tyt are like yeah
sure we're on the same page
that's not a page you you don't want to
be like oh yeah look uh-huh tyt Nick
Fuentes all right great we uh when I get
the roundabout I get the roundabout way
that she's doing it right I get the
roundabout way that she's doing it she's
trying to say I identify as this and you
can but I I have never
I I've never call I've never heard
anyone call women that and I I didn't
see where she posted that someone called
her that specifically the only time I've
ever heard those things or it's like you
know childbearing or this or that is
from Republicans those are the ones who
have used those terms to be like oh
they're you know the Earthen vessel
they're a [__] right but she's using
the trans she's using it as a hammer to
attack the trans Community because she's
saying oh that she said transphobia and
it just man you're trying you're trying
out the wokism stuff and you got I I see
what you're doing I see what you're
doing you're trying it out and you're
seeing how it's gonna work
and I see what's going on I see what's I
see what we're doing okay so um let's go
back to this is it what what is why is
there a reason why you put them on there
is that that clip that I showed there
was the clip that we played yesterday
the whole like uh women want to be raved
and they don't yeah they wanted all this
[__] I was like oh God that's exactly
why he's on there and that's one of the
reasons why he made it onto the bonehead
Madness uh
in particular let me see well I mean
many clips that he's done over the last
year Well explain who this guy is give
the audience an idea who Nick Fuentes is
real quick in a nutshell right Nick
Fuentes is a Nazi that's perfect that's
perfect I don't you don't need to know
more than that he he loves he loves
Putin he loves Hitler he loves joking
about the genocide and the Holocaust of
the Jewish Community uh by Hitler he uh
is transphobic he hates gay people he
says he's celibate by choice uh no it's
because women don't want anything to do
with him you'll see why here in a second
yeah uh because you know you I mean yeah
we call him an incel right but that's
involuntary right and incel is
involuntary which means that it's it's
not their choice right and I think that
is true he says it's voluntary so he's
like oh I'm a [__] evolve cell I
think he's what he said once shut the
[__] up no he's not doing it what a
vowel cell like voluntarily
oh so he's saying elements instead of
involuntarily celibate that's what he
doesn't want to have but he's a Nazi
through and through the kid is a [__]
Nazi and now he's back on Twitter and
all these other places and the guy spews
nothing but hatred bigotry
it's it's he's a this God I hate this
[__] kid okay let's let's listen to
uh the Nazi here let's see what he says
about women I I'm not surprised why
women don't support me women are
irrational and sensitive it's just like
my whole life my whole life
oh my God because I was always like the
class clown I was always like bullying
women
and really women women have always been
like simultaneously Charmed but also
doubted
nope uh like oh stop it oh oh you're so
annoying you know you know what I mean
that kind of thing
that's how women are with like uh
they didn't say it like that with like
my personality type or you're like a
rascal you know Rascal Rascal I think
what you meant is you're like my
personality type a rapist
he's getting the r words confused you're
like mustard
and they're kind of like I didn't point
this out the other day but why is he
fidgeting with that cup because he's
lying
oh oh you're saying you're saying it's
an instinct to fidget with that cup
because yeah how people are like oh wait
look up this way when I'm trying to
think of like an excuse kind of thing
and like you're fidgeting with something
as a way to distract or or focus on it
or whatever it is like it makes it
whether it makes them uncomfortable or
not I don't know but he's lying 100 and
I'm sure if there was like a body like
language expert they would probably tell
you this is one of the signs of or this
might be his tell of what he's doing of
his deception here of yeah yeah because
I think it's also it it shows that he's
weak right like this is I and again I'm
not a body language expert but from what
I've seen before and heard a similar
type of situations like the fidgeting is
one where like you can't you won't make
eye contact right like you don't feel
like you're you're high enough in the
respect kind of category or or class you
know you're like fidgeting with
something to distract yourself from like
not you know looking up and saying
things like it's because one it's he's
lying these are not the ways in which
women interact with him no one's ever
been like oh stop it you're so cute it's
like no stop it you're [__] creepy no
get the hell yeah you're like oh little
rascal no you [__] rapist like you're
[__] Nazi you're a [__] creep
you're terrible you're garbage you're
horrible these are things that women if
they actually do ever interact with Nick
Fuentes say about him once he's opened
his [__] mouth and said the things
that he says about women or anyone in
the lgbtq community or anyone who's of
color
those are the things that immediately
will turn off someone and I think even
for conservative people they're like oh
dude you're [__] little too Nazi
right right right you're a little ixnay
on the Hitler
but listen to what he goes on to say
about
um how women want to be
our word we're raped and you'll know
what we're talking about when he means
rapist when he means a rascal or when he
says rascal
because I'm like a rule breaker and
stuff
the law breaker so women simultaneously
are intrigued by that but they're also
they also have to pretend like they're
not because women no they're not it's
sort of like how women a lot of women
want to be raped when I say raped I mean
like that's awesome say it like that
yeah yeah it sounds really bad when you
say that like it's bad when you say that
because it is bad right when you say
that because you believe that that women
want to this is it's crazy [__] man it's
crazy [__] but this is why he's the
alpha cook let's let's keep going here
but there's like a lot of women that
really want a guy to beat the [__] out
of them no
but also they have to pretend but part
of it is they have to pretend like they
don't so there's there's the
justification look we get to beat the
[__] out of them because they want to be
and then pretend like they don't want to
be right I mean that's it's [__] nuts
I wonder I wonder why it is that Nick
Fuentes can't find a a mate
I'm wondering yeah I mean why he can't
find his Earthen vessel right he can't
find his um
yeah I don't it's
wow it's so it's so sad to see people
like talk like this because you there's
a there's a part of me and it's like man
I feel kind of bad for him but then I'm
also like nah he says some pretty shitty
stuff so I don't really feel bad for him
at all right but like you know he is a
he is a product of his own environment
right he created this he's the one who
pushes the ideas that that his community
builds him up for right and says oh dude
[__] Nick Fuentes dude big dick
energy this bro he you know it's no well
but you know that's a good point about
his audience because
I I think you're right when he's doing
the whole fidgeting thing he's lying and
the reason why he's doing that he's
fidgeting and lying is because of this
is because he's lying about how women
like him and but they don't really show
it and then when he said he stopped
fidgeting when he said this stuff about
women love to be raped women love to
have the [__] beat out of him he
actually believes that [__] yeah and the
reason why he's saying this to his
honest you got to remember who his
audience is his audience are people and
and men white men in particular that
look and act and and just like him and
they're not getting women they're not
getting women and they're frustrated
probably because they're the Jordan
Peterson right type crowd right and and
he has to explain to them why they're
not and why it's good
and why it's a great thing
that this is happening like this don't
worry this is the part for the course
this is a good thing that you're not
having relationships with other human
beings because you're a pile of [__]
right I mean this is a good thing that's
what he's trying to sell to him come
here and and be with me and the other
pie all of us piles a [__] together
right I mean that's what he's saying to
his audience that's really what he's
doing here
um but [__] Nick Fuentes [__] that Nazi
because that's what he is yeah we should
we should dump him in the trash bin of
History
um as far as taking him seriously but
the problem is is he has an audience
that he [__] that he talks to and
there's a lot of people out there that
believe this garbage and the only way
for us to actually undo this mind [__]
that these people have done is to expose
them like we do here on bone end of the
week so
we just exposed a Nick Fuentes once
again as Alpha cook I think this is
um not the first time he's appeared as
Alpha cook no he's been on here before
for
we'll say similar viewpoints right you
know I mean
is it all I mean it's his only
viewpoints he's got speaking of
viewpoints
um we're gonna have to get going here
because we gotta get to this uh Jack
Smith thing so there's two gangs that
are in trouble with Jack Smith here on
the moment of the week we got Donald
Trump and then we've got Evan Karen
Cochran
Cox you guys are with the dick Channel
stuff today
um so Evan Cochran what what's going on
with that guy this morning Gabe Sanchez
that he and what happened this week that
he's on bone end of the week well well
yeah he found himself on bonehead yeah
because uh so I believe was the
Appellate Court right they were like all
right look you've got till midnight
to to issue your response on why
he doesn't need to testify right he
doesn't need to give a deposition or or
give a statement to Jack Smith right
and the doj you've got until 6 a.m so
they're going to respond at 12 and you
got till 6 a.m to respond
so I think it was like probably I think
like I think they each got about six
hours or something like that or whatever
right uh so they were submitted by they
submitted by midnight
and then the doj [__] uh was it 4 500
3400 6400 was it 6400 I'm trying to
remember how many words
they wrote
in less than six hours which was their
response prepared yeah yeah but also
it's like dude I could only I can
remember when I was writing essays in in
high school and college and be like all
right you got to have a five-page essay
and it's got to be done by the time and
I'm like [__] all right let me Rush uh
you've got a team of people who are you
know who obviously know what are going
to be the the arguments that are made
but also like [__] man that's pretty
impressive so they got in at like 5 53
a.m or something like that
then by I want to say what was like a
few hours after the fact the Appellate
the judges who were on this were like
yeah you're gonna have to give them
everything everything which is from what
we understand there are recordings
between Corcoran and Trump written notes
uh and I I think those are probably the
the top two like evidential like pieces
of of information and then also
obviously he himself
uh have to has to present himself to
Jack Smith to get interviewed and here's
here's the reason why is because the the
how they're using the crime fraud
exemption here is that what what the doj
and Jack Smith are essentially claiming
is that Donald Trump used
Corcoran his attorney to cover crime
with with attorney-client privilege and
how he's doing that is he's deceiving
intentionally his attorney now I believe
that the doj and and the pellet uh Court
the three judges that made this decision
um who are randomly chosen by the way
this wasn't this this was not some like
ah they're coming after him
randomly chosen right
um and the reason why this isn't going
to the Supreme Court is because they're
Expediting this
um that may be the reason why they're
Expediting but I I think it probably has
to do with National Security and why
Trump is lying to his attorney Trump
does this all the time this is his Mo
right this is one of his this is one of
the ways that he does major delays is he
his intention a lot of times is to get
an attorney
off a case the court will not let the
attorney continue right that way he has
to hire a new attorney that way he can
delay he can be like well well this new
attorney has to get up the speed he has
to learn the case at which the attorney
does this is a this was a stall tactic
um probably by Trump to feed his
attorney's false information what he
didn't realize probably is that he's in
deep [__] with Jacks Jack Smith Jack
Smith is not going to let this slide now
uh here's uh Kyle Chaney um tweeted this
morning update Cochran is now entering
the grand jury space of the courthouse
for his anticipated testimony in the
Trump documents case that was at 7 49 my
time so that's 8 49 Eastern I'm not sure
if he's come out of that testimony space
um or that grand jury space where he has
anticipated to give his testimony but
this testimony is not in defense of
trump like he was doing yesterday on the
Mike Pence thing because yesterday
apparently there was a hearing on rather
Mike Pence will be forced to comply with
the subpoena with the grand jury and
Jack Smith the special counsel
um and and Trump's attorney showed up at
that hearing we're not going to see a
lot of this stuff because a lot of is
under seal with this document stuff
because a lot of this stuff has to do
with classified information and that's
all in the doing of Donald Trump here
when he stole those documents in the
first place and he obstructed which is I
believe
what what Trump's attorney is going to
have to testify today now
there's a lot of different components
here uh rather Corcoran is in big
trouble or not because Corcoran either
one or two things could have known that
Trump was obstructing and knew he was uh
lying to him or he could have not known
yeah I mean there's that possibility
there's two possibilities either this
attorney knew that Trump was lying to
him or didn't but I mean really honestly
could you sit in a room with this guy
Trump
and [__] think well he's telling the
whole truth like are you serious like
why do you think everyone [__]
records him even Brad rafflesberger the
Secretary of State all the way back
during the big lie was like I gotta
record this [__] if he's saying
something because he's not even his
people know they're like
one it might turn out to be uh some good
right like in terms of like oh that's a
laugh but also people are like uh I
probably want to have proof of him
saying what he's saying because he's not
only he's gonna lie to me when he says
it but then he's gonna lie about what he
said the lies to me so I better record
this [__] that's why there's so many
recordings of trump
and I don't know why this guy gets on
the phone I can't imagine why Donald
Trump does any meaning on the phone
anymore he's got to know he's being
[__] recorded right yeah that's good
I mean you gotta know that based on the
uh on his history that somebody most
likely is going to record him uh
but he goes nope love to hear my own
voice love to hear my own voice and
that's exactly probably why he does it
and also probably he thinks that he's
you know his ego is so big that he
thinks that he could get away with
anything he's like I could say whatever
I want he's the same guy who said I
could [__] shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue and no one would do anything
right well I mean that that is his brand
and yeah he did it intentionally he did
that intentionally there's other news
with this appeals court decision though
um because and Kyle points it out a side
note and this is I think this is really
important in this case
um yesterday the same appeal score panel
that rejected efforts to block
corcoran's testimony made an identical
ruling and another sealed case that we
have yet to identify
um this case has to do with stored
Communications either a phone or email
um maybe it's email on a phone or phone
records it's unclear but it does have to
do about a device
um it's stored Communications case that
Hal decided on March 3rd now we do know
this we do know
that Scott Perry the congressman from
Pennsylvania the one that was supposed
to deliver some of those uh fake State
electors to Mike Pence before they were
wanted to hang him you know on January
6th before he had to run away because
they want to name him he was he seems he
seems to forget that but right but Scott
Perry was supposed to deliver those fake
state state electors and he's had his
cell phone seized by the federal
authorities in this matter uh it is
likely that Jack Smith and the special
counsel and the grand jury are trying to
get into that cell phone and Scott Perry
has been trying to block them ever since
in court so we don't know if that's the
case but we know that that exists
and this little side note where they're
they're making a ruling on a stored
communication on a phone or an email
um seems kind of you know A and B kind
of line up to make those dots connect so
that could be it that could be it and
let me tell you something if this starts
to
um if if Jack Smith starts to rap in and
wrap his arms around members of Congress
here for January 6. holy [__] you just
wait for the [__] fireworks to happen
now here's here's what my personal
belief is
um on this situation
because we are going to go to Donald
Trump as as the winner of bonehead here
obviously
um because it's a great segue into it
because he's Jesus Christ stall bone and
stuff uh because I'm going to read you
some of his statements that he's made on
true social over the last 24 hours but
here's what I believe about the
indictments because everyone's wanting
to know who's going to go first uh the
Manhattan D.A or is it
um Jack Smith now there's the Manhattan
D.A has delayed but there was no s there
was no talk other than Donald Trump
Donald Trump is the only the only person
that said he was going to be arrested
last week that's what we had to go off
of now like Gabe Sanchez said even on
Saturday he said this it's probably a
[__] line which it turned out to be
he wasn't he wasn't arrested last
Tuesday yeah um I think he wasn't
intentionally lying I just think he he's
an idiot and he doesn't know how it
works and he's seen that Costello his
attorney his other another [__]
attorney had to go [__] defend his
lies
um to the grand jury in Manhattan he
knew he was going to go do this and his
attorneys told him that's not going to
work that's not going to help that's not
going to do the deed they're still going
to indict you more than likely so he
thought Costello goes in on Monday so
I'll be indicted on Tuesday which means
I'm arrested on Tuesday you know that's
how it is but also I mean like whether
he knew or not like he raised you know
what has been reported over a million
and a half dollars and so it's like
again it's one of those things where
it's like again if he
it's like God damn it man you guys are
so [__] dumb he says that he's a
billionaire right he says that he's a
very he says a lot he says
we know that he he's lied right it's
like 30 000 plus lies in four years that
he made while he was president
uh
but the thing that that gets me is like
he goes I'm you know I'm a I'm a I'm a
very smart businessman and I made a lot
of money and I'm super wealthy and I've
got billions of dollars well if you
millions of dollars then defending
yourself
for a dumb crime that you think is not
really there
shouldn't cost you much money and I'm
sure you could negotiate someone well I
guess that's more in a civil case but
you negotiate uh you know the other
party to cover the damages
but even in this he's like oh look I'm
so wealthy and I'm so rich but you know
what
I need you guys to pay for my legal fund
I need you guys to cover the cost of
paying for my lawyer
that I said I would pay but I don't have
the money and uh look my money's tied up
and some stuff here and there so I got I
I need you guys to pay for it and every
time these people like yeah dude I got a
second mortgage on the house uh I I
drain my kids college fund 401K gone
dude everything gone for this guy and
the guy again people I mean there were
some people that spoke out from January
6 who were like he doesn't care about
you he's not coming for you he didn't
come for us so what makes you think this
is gonna be any different do not risk
your your safety your freedom
by going to protest and commit violence
and don't don't give this guy any more
money some people spoke out who have
seen the light but other people were
like ah [__] it man you know I'm gonna
give him everything I got everything I
got give me everything you got right and
that's what they did they gave him
everything they got right well and and I
think that is why he's gonna go to Waco
uh tomorrow is because he's he's making
this an official campaign event
um it's an official campaign rally and
the reason why is because he's going to
get indicted yeah okay and that and that
is a signal that he's doing a couple
different things he thinks it's going to
spark this big this big Uprising with
his support
um that he's went to Waco and it sends
these signals it's it's gonna be it's
gonna go over like a wet fart in a white
thong folks it's just not going to go
over well for him right and I I believe
the reason why the Manhattan D.A has has
slowed their role down a little bit with
the grand jury is because it's likely
that Jack Smith has notified
um The Manhattan D.A and said hey we're
we're probably gonna make a move on
obstruction and it appears that way that
Jack Smith will be making a move on
obstruction because as I explained the
other day there's going to be
superseding indictments if he gets the
first charge on obstruction yeah you can
get him on other charges after the fact
they don't have to bring all the charges
at once that's not how it works which
which by the way I just want to bring
something up that I haven't really seen
anyone talk about but yeah he made a
video the other day that we've played
right where he goes oh these four bogus
uh right radical left charges right
at the very end of the video uh because
I I have a FaceTime call that I was
going to do yesterday but it's coming
out today
there's a FaceTime or the he did a video
where he goes to these things he says
all these bogus charges and he goes
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you which no they're
definitely coming after you yeah uh he
goes right right right right but but
yeah but the but the normal people right
the average average American who who is
sitting by he's like they're not coming
after me they're coming after you right
because it's like oh if they could come
after me they can come after you kind of
[__] but he's like it's because I'm
standing in their way yeah it's [__]
obstruction right and then it goes and I
will do abstractions and I will continue
to stand in their way so you're
committing you're you're going to
continue right to commit obstruction
fine you know what [__] it man you do
you you commit these crimes but the idea
he's like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna defend
you guys by standing in the way okay
dude
let's see how that works out for you
Grandpa here's how he woke up this
morning this is she woke up he woke up
with a shitty diaper this is this is his
good morning
misconduct he's he really needs to turn
up of
prosecutorial misconduct yeah he's I
swear he's gonna give himself an
aneurysm right like any day now this the
[__]
like this is this it's like that scene
in um
uh was it Total Recall with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and they go outside and
they're exposed to the Mars era and he's
like and his eyes if I could have
popping out [__] yeah
[__] this is how he woke up this morning
folks
um so I wonder
um who's who is most scared the Alvin
Bragg the Manhattan d8 my Jack Smith or
this guy who who obviously [__] the bed
last night
um when he wakes up like that but I want
to show you the statement that
everyone's been talking about here
um that he put out I think this was late
into the night last night so he
obviously didn't get his Beauty Rest
um with his good morning because he was
up late
um typing in [__] like this he says what
kind of person can charge another person
that would be a prosecutor by the way
that's what kind of person but you know
what kind of people do this that's a
prosecutor that's what they're called
generally you should know you've seen a
lot of them right he says what kind of
person can charge another person in this
case a former president United States
why does he refer to himself as a former
president of the United States isn't he
the guy who said the 20 uh 20 election
was stolen wouldn't that make him the
president I mean I I would make him the
current president this is [__] crazy
this case a former president of the
United States who got more votes than
any sitting president in history he
keeps bringing that up and that that
little dick energy again he's not wrong
right
that what the [__] that got to do with
it right right but what but that's the
thing so like when God okay it's like
God damn dude you guys don't understand
[__] Math and how it's broken
how one per how one person gets more
votes than the other person like the
semantics of what he's saying right now
are correct right he got more votes than
any sitting president in history that is
true but if we acknowledge the fact that
over time our country the United States
of America has increased in population
which would mean there's a direct
relationship with the amount of of
eligible voters right who would vote for
him he's going to get more votes so if
the previous election there were more
votes then the next election can be more
votes in the next election more and more
and more well you know this it's it's
the [__] yes it is true more votes
than any sitting president however that
doesn't mean you're the [__] winner
because there was a person Joe Biden
President Joe Biden who got almost eight
more million or eight million more votes
than he did
from a basement from a base from a
basement where he was asleep on a Volcan
Lazy Boy but that's what people wait
wait wait I thought Joe Biden's woke you
just said he was asleep how can he be
asleep and woke all at the same time you
can be woke but asleep but it's
different when you wake up I see I know
if you you're not like if you're woke
you're asleep right well here's way
here's what I want to know here's what I
want to know what kind of person what
kind of person can win can win by eight
million votes and still be the president
of the United States this is ridiculous
okay so he goes on to say here here's
what he goes on to say the leading
candidate by far for the Republican
Party nomination what the [__] does that
mean there's you're not on a ballot
friend you're not on about it now here
we go here we go it gets I it gets a
little crazy here I'm not gonna lie he
makes a lot of turns here with a crime
and he doesn't have periods he he does
this comma thing I don't know if he
knows that anyways with a crime when it
is known by all that no crime has been
committed what does that mean with a
crime what
and then when it is known by all a
person can charge another person oh
because it's [__] super low so what
kind of here I'll just cut out the the
nonsense what kind of person can charge
another person with a good crime oh I
see so he's he's doing you have to cut
four lines right but you'll get there
four lines it's like a paragraph no I
know because you have to cut out this
the whole thing this case of a former
president United States who got more
voting because he's got to get all those
digs yeah he's got to get all of that
right he's gotta fluff himself up right
but really what matters here is what
kind of person can charge another person
with a crime that's a prosecution that's
a prosecutor that's what kind of person
a prosecutor can charge another person a
criminal
Liz Harrington I think usually listens
to our show so Liz uh welcome if you're
on your soccer account listening
um let the guy know I'm just saying just
slip him a note on his desk or in his
golf bag or something all right I got it
this is pretty funny victory
foreign
[Laughter]
oh [__]
I don't think that is right I don't
think that I don't know no definitely
could be I don't think I had a [__] I
don't know I'm not even gonna go there
um Liz slip the guy in note let him know
that the person that can charge another
person with the crime they're called a
prosecutor generally generally they're
elected or they're appointed by an
elected official I just want to let you
know that that you can anyways let's
move on from that nonsense he says when
it is known by all the that all but oh
Jesus by all that no crime has been
committed listen there is apparently
someone someone who knows I'm sorry I'm
still stuck on the victims I can't get
it out of my head now it's too good
Flynn is a Flynn Flynn is a traitor on
on Twitch Bravo whoever whoever you are
whoever you are
big to me oh man we're stealing that
[__] by the way we're stealing that [__]
that's good ah
um okay so let's see if I can collect it
together and see if we can continue
[Laughter]
no no the shadow in the back knows yeah
okay
and also known that potential death and
destruction this is what people are
really mad about
death and destruction
in such a false charge could be
catastrophic for our country question
mark
now he's putting the question mark there
because he says what kind of person and
that's the end of that question I mean
it's all really good it's a really long
one two three four five six seven eight
nine nine lines right to get to the
question right Jesus Christ anyways he
goes on to ask or maybe it's not yeah
okay here's the next question it's a
much shorter question and he says why
and who would do such a thing
a prosecutor in the jurisdiction where
you committed a crime
why is this so hard it's weird because
you're like hey look there was this
thing that happened and it was in it was
within my purview and I'm in the one
that is responsible because I am the one
who represents that area right
it I listen a lot of people were really
pissed off about this statement
um and they're up in arms because he
says potential death and destruction
because he's calling for violence but
everyone he's been calling for viola and
he's going to continue on the stage at
wake I mean tomorrow
he is definitely more direct about it in
this right right he was more subtle
we'll say when he said protest protest
protest protest right
hey wait I didn't get to the last line
here maybe maybe I'm on the maybe he's
on to something here hang on
he says in victories
[Laughter]
he says
only a degenerate psychopath that truly
hates the USA so they're not they're not
prosecutors anymore apparently their
their titles are degenerate Psychopaths
it it
kind of Rich coming from this guy that
he's calling someone else
a degenerate psychopath I mean someone
else hold on someone else wrote in here
I thought this is pretty good too wait
wait wait wait I gotta find it
[Music]
there we go Trump also suffers from
liabides
foreign
the chat is good today the chat is good
today thank you David the dick chat is
uh good today wow
we do have the best audience in the
world the dick dialogue let me tell you
today it is
super [__] rock solid you know I was
gonna try to think of something to say
about this statement
[Laughter]
I ain't got a [__]
[__] thing I wish I had a clip or
something but I can't stop thinking
about how this fat guy with diabetes
keeps yelling into the true social
machine and victimies
oh my God it's [__] Friday yeah and
Donald Trump is the bonehead of the week
oh my God Gabe Sanchez
let's give let's give Grandpa liabidi's
his due
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Music]
you [__] in the chat God damn
oh man you're the best audience in the
world you truly truly are the best
audience in the world and this has been
bonehead of the week don't forget
bonehead Madness is gonna have you
already started tweeting these things
out they're already done okay yeah so
build up go go right now to at Tony
Michaels pod and um go go vote right now
and see if I can pull them up and show
them to you go right now and go vote for
the Sinister 16 and over here right now
let's see this is game one tomorrow
we'll pull up game two okay so here's
all your here's all your centers to 16s
game one the lane stream
um
media's region is between Michael
Knowles and Sean Hannity who advance
from the sixth Sinners or 16 to the
hateful eight comment below with your
reason all right so who should I vote
for who do you think oh I'm gonna go
with the wow whoa look look at the score
in this game wow so the score in this
game is Michael Knowles is losing
wow by 50 wow that's crazy okay so so to
throw it down there's only 16 votes it
is early on in this game yeah so go vote
in game one of the lame stream media's
region between Michael Knowles and Sean
Hannity participate in the bonehead
Madness all weekend these polls you're
gonna see them again you're gonna see
these on at Tony Michael's pod on
Twitter that's where we're going to be
voting we're not going to put these on
um YouTube it's just way too complicated
so it's only going to be a bonehead man
it's only gonna be on Twitter so if you
have a Twitter account
and you're [__] you know that's how it
goes what are you gonna do
um so if you want to participate go open
up a Twitter account do not subscribe to
Twitter blue did you see that [__] yeah
dude did you see that [__] he's gonna go
down go to Williams go to Williams
account there okay well let's do this
let's in bone end of the week and then
we'll we'll talk about let's talk about
Twitter blue
um right after this has been your
edition of bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week
okay well we oh we're gonna look at the
Twitter blue thing yeah so go to because
because I go to William William's been
uh been following it uh well because he
got he he has several different Twitter
accounts and um and they keep soliciting
him to
um you know give up his his blue check
so what's happening is there's a thing
called Legacy blue chick explain to
Yanni is what a legacy blue check is so
a legacy blue check are all the people
who are actual of like celebrity notable
status you know reporters uh athletes
what have you right these are the people
that had blue check marks before right
and the only way to get a blue check
mark at that time was you had to be of
some sort of notable status right right
either in the media or right right uh
well no variety right like even people
you know there were even some people
that Jan six insurrectionists were of
notable status based on the fact that
they were [__] talked about and in
the news and this and that so right
because they had they had quote media
credits right yeah exactly which you
only have to show I think a minimum of
three like articles that someone talks
about YouTube and I think you used to
have to apply for this if they and
sometimes they just give it
automatically but right right some
people if they're like oh that's act you
know that's like right if you're like a
real celebration yeah right they'll give
it to you but other people had to apply
for and prove that they were who they
said they were now that is notable right
those are that's the that is Legacy as
as Elon Musk has it now the new way that
it is is anyone with with eight by could
buy a blue check mark right and the only
way that you would know if they were
real or not real is if you hover over
their uh their username yeah the blue
check mark and it would say this person
is subscribed to Twitter blue or this
person has Legacy blue and we can't tell
you if they're notable or not right can
you can you um
can you hide that your blue check like
if you buy Twitter
um you know if you do Twitter blue can
you hide it so so that's the thing you
can't hide it right now but it sounds
like on April sounds like on whether
this is a joke or not I have no idea it
could be yeah right now that I'm
thinking that April 1st with Elon Musk
this could be some stupid thing right
gotcha gotcha [__] idiot but
according to what's being reported uh
organizations will now have to pay a
thousand dollars here's well I'm gonna
show you will Hannah posted so he got an
email from The Help Center
uh will a gate I don't know if you know
who elegate is but he he's one of the
owners at pillow fight company
um uh him and um David Hogg started
another pillow company and they've
acquired a few other companies and now
it's called pillow fightco
um he said my company pellifico was
paying
ten thousand dollars a month in ads
before Elon Musk took over okay so they
were paying his company was paying to
have social media ads pop up in your
feed
um which a lot of companies do so they
were paying 10 almost 120 000 a year we
cut that to eight dollars a month for a
blue check due to elon's changes to the
app so in other words he went and gave
Elon Musk eight bucks a month
um for the blue check but he stopped
advertising with it he says now our new
spend will be zero and here's why let me
uh pull this up so this is the email
from The Help Center again or the
message from The Help Center yet it says
a Twitter verified organization which is
different than a legacy check right so
it's different than a legacy check
there's three there's three colors and
there's also organizations so what how
it looks is you see a blue check mark
and right now that's that's a person who
pays for Twitter blue or is a legacy but
everything will switch over to this new
you have to pay for it system then
there's a yellow uh
uh
check mark symbol and that's used for
organizations like CNN New York Times
ESPN stuff like that that they can be
verified yeah oh no that's how it is
right there and then when you go into
government organizations like the doj
the FBI stuff like that those are gray
so when you see gray check marks they're
government agencies when you see yellow
check marks they're companies and when
you see blue check marks they are uh
people okay so that's how it's supposed
to be so it says here that a Twitter
verified organization subscription for
Twitter blue
is going to be a thousand dollars a
month and they to have a check mark this
isn't like
they to get their check mark regardless
they have to pay a thousand dollars a
month plus taxes of course and fifty
dollars a month for each additional
Affiliated affiliate in the US so Elon
Musk now is because you said the
government
check marks are they gonna have the same
thing do you know if they're gonna have
to pay a thousand bucks wouldn't be
surprised I mean who knows they could
they could say that uh so he's gonna Rob
our government money by giving them
verified accounts which the amendment is
100 gonna do they have to at this point
right now organizations won't have to
and I doubt [__] individuals are
going to give this son of a [__] eight
dollars just to keep their legacy check
I wouldn't [__] that [__] no I don't I
the only people that you'll find with
blue check marks you'll probably find is
gonna be like a lot of right-wing people
right well there will be a lot of people
I think there will be a lot of people if
you can actually
if you can actually hide your blue check
because there's actually [__] that that
the blue check has now that you used to
have access to like two-factor often uh
um up Jesus Christ yes anyways you could
do a two-factor to where someone doesn't
hack into your account
um you get longer videos there's some
other [__] that um that did or did not
used to be part of your just your
regular Twitter account that's part of
Twitter blue now like you have to buy it
to get these things yeah
um so anyways so they're going to change
the price for organizations to be a
thousand dollars a month
um which is [__] crazy to me but the
thing I want to know is the government
ones because this it's a government
because you know why I just I'm in I'm
in that page right now here
I'll send you the links so many people
can see this because this is what we do
we [__] fact check in real time
people boom [__] so bring it with you
if you click that link
and you go to it
mm-hmm
Fair side organizations okay
[__] decline organization
organization type business government so
this would make me think right that it's
both government
all government agencies will now have to
pay a thousand dollars a month
and 50 a month for each Affiliated
account which I don't know how that
works exactly it looks like the doj
let's say the doj has their main page
and then they have all the other pages
that are like their districts right like
Southern District yeah yeah yeah okay
that makes sense so you have the doj's
page and then you have dojs at each one
of their sub accounts right right for
like each district so that's that's
where I mean that's the quickest way
that Elon because we have to remember
that Elon is he has to pay back billions
this year so wait wait a second wait a
second so what about the members of
Congress and [__]
do they have gray checks that's what I'm
asking yeah they have great checks so so
each member of Congress is going to have
to pay 12 000 a year to have their gray
check you know I wonder here's the thing
so I wonder if it's if it's the
organization is the House of
Representatives right or the Senate
and then the are they Affiliates of them
here that's what I want to know so this
is a this is aoc's uh this is not her
official rep page yeah yeah but she has
a great check you see that yeah house
rent yeah
so she's gonna have to pay twelve
thousand dollars a year to keep this
great check on this account
it's not that's her personal account so
if I had to look at that I would say
okay well she'd have to pay eight
dollars right because she's not an
organization right they gave her that
great check mark I'm assuming so she
would have to pay eight dollars a month
to keep the blue check mark because
that's her personal right but here's a
check mark yeah I don't see like that's
what I don't know like is I don't
I would think it would be 50 every
person because they're all under the
House of Representatives
that's the organization right that's how
I would think of it but I don't know
it's a hard thing to say well but I mean
so let's let's surmise here so she's got
this is her official count this would be
the one that does fifty dollars a month
and the one we just looked at is her
personal account
huh so that would be eight dollars no
not if it's a government check yeah no
no but there's no reason that other one
should be a government check that's her
personal account I I don't know what to
say I'm showing you I'm just I know I
know but that's I think what happened is
Twitter changed that on her behalf to be
like she's a government representative
but so so what you're saying is is this
account as of April 1st will have a blue
check and she'll pay eight bucks
that's the way that it should go right
because that one is just her personal
account right just like empty greeny and
then rep MTG right the rep MTG from RJ
Taylor green should be gray and uh and
MTV empty greeny sure let's go check it
out well and the reason why this matters
tell the audience because this sounds
trivial right but this is going to
matter again because we did this check
mark thing [__] months ago and it
confused a lot of people why is this
this is going to [__] everything up
again so the reason this is gonna [__]
everything up again is because
originally you saw the Eli Lilly
situation that happened in other
organizations were like oh or or people
right we're like I'm going to buy a blue
check mark and I'm going to do that and
then I'm going to disparage let's say
the companies that by pretending to be
them right
so in addition to that now we have three
types of check marks because Elon said
hey we should give everyone a blue check
mark and the people on trust and safety
were like nope we shouldn't do that
because that's dumb because bad stuff is
gonna happen and then bad stuff happened
for like I don't know a week or so
before they they locked it down and they
didn't let anyone do it again then they
said okay we have a new plan in place
and we're going to make two new check
marks so it's gonna be blue it's gonna
be yellow and it's gonna be gray right
or a blue gold gray is what it is
and so see this is what it should be
right this is what AOC should be but I
highly because I I don't know if AOC
that was I think that was just done on
our behalf I think they just did it to
her and again I'm just using these
accounts as examples because you guys
know who these people are but the reason
this is your professional account yeah
and the reason this is going to be such
a big deal is because not only did
before they were like ah well who's the
blue check mark who's real who's not
now it's like okay we implemented a
system so that you could tell who was
real and who's not especially if they're
a company or if they're an organization
as like a government agency right and
the one reason why is because like Liam
Liam Neeson yeah Nissan is a parody
account and like Kevin Sorbo thought he
was actually right yeah yeah so you
could be interacting with people that
you think are real but they're actually
not real but what's going on really who
you think it is right exactly I mean
that's the internet too you're talking
to someone who you don't really know who
it is right uh I've never met Tony so I
don't know if that's really who he is
what the [__] I'm some sort of AI
experiment that's all I am is Gabe's AI
folks that's all it is you've been
talking to my AI this whole time but
this this other this other part is going
to be a problem now too because now you
have government agencies
and you have uh actual organizations
companies
and now those people have to pay to play
so you know
you donate well there's a lot of
problems but you donate to your
representative your donation now has to
be used
to pay for the [__] check mark on
Twitter right okay so you're someone who
was asking someone was asking who Liam
Nissan is this is who Kev this literally
is the account yeah that Kevin this is I
just want to point out I just want to
point out we've officially hit three
hours [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah we
know we know we can do anything hours
[__] anyway we could do four
out we could do probably five hours
there's enough [__] to go around I mean
yeah
but yeah it's stupid all around because
what is going to happen is there's gonna
be more confusion and more people being
like I'm not gonna pay for that
and also the common person is not going
to know the difference if you make an
account and pay eight dollars to be the
doj let's say and the doj's like [__]
that I'm not paying a thousand bucks
plus fifty dollars every like right
additional partner which they will
because it's the government they have
right right they have to and it's a
forced position obviously but it's one
of those things where you could have an
agency you could have an organization or
a company that says nope not going to do
it
so now that person isn't going to verify
who they are as legitimate and someone
else is going to come back in and be
like ah I'm the real one
and we're gonna [__] find ourselves
in this whole thing again right well but
yeah holding companies hostage is what
he's doing right the other thing that I
think is going to happen is
um the traffic is going to dump off
Twitter it's not gonna go well for him
and the reason why is because a lot of
these big accounts that get a ton of
[__] activity that that use Twitter a
lot and if they're an organization like
[__] you I'm not paying you twelve
thousand dollars to have this account
that's not I mean I'm not I don't make
12 000 off this [__] Twitter account
so an organization that's in business
for profit is not going to pay Elon Musk
12 000 hours
and the other thing too is uh the fact
that you would hold a government age so
here
Elon Musk says in others be like hey
there should be more transparency there
should be more transparency about what
happens within the government right and
Twitter is probably the closest thing
that you'll get to that because that's
where you'll find them say hey we charge
this person here's this investigation
this is this that's the status here here
because No One's Gonna Know to go to
[__] C-SPAN or go to the website and
look this [__] up right there's so much
stuff that's happening
beneath the surface that nobody knows
about and the only reason that many
people do know about it is because they
follow these social media accounts right
and Twitter is the closest thing you'll
get to transparency so the idea
that Elon Musk advocates for
transparency but then holds these
companies and these organizations
hostage by saying if you want people to
know that you are really who you say you
are
then you need to pay me a thousand bucks
a month that doesn't really make a lot
of sense if you think about the logic of
what Elon Musk and the rest of these
idiots want to talk about you're now
saying in order for you to prove Who You
Are
to be transparent with us
you have to pay it's [__] exportion
well I mean
we knew Elon Musk was going to be in
this trouble because I think apparently
he's like 113 billion dollars or
something
it's 10 to 13 billion I think okay I
don't remember it was like a billion and
a half or whatever interest coming up
this spring summer time
he's [__] anyways so that is that is
the show for this week we definitely
went the three hours
uh we know we can do three hours we know
this we know we can we would do it it
just has to be feasible for us we've
been doing it on Fridays we would do it
Monday through Friday
um but you know this is our job and
we've got to make some scratch so here's
how you can help with that effort here's
how you can help there's some free ways
to do it you can subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast right here on YouTube
don't forget to subscribe we just we
just went over fifteen thousand today 15
000 subs thank you to the audience today
for getting us to 15 000. let's let's go
for 20. that's our goal let's get to 20
000 subscribers let's do it so that's a
free way go ahead and subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast another three ways
to follow us at Tony Michaels pod you
can do bonehead Madness all the way into
the weekend bonehead is extended this
weekend
uh for the bonehead Madness Championship
you also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google and just go download it on all of
them to hell with it just go download it
on all of them are just your favorite
that's free that's free 99. you if you
still have a Facebook account you can
follow us at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook you can subscribe to the up
wires YouTube channel that's free that's
free sport
you can also link your Amazon Prime
account to Twitch this is a free way to
give us money what you just you all you
do is you just link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account and you
give that one free subscription that you
get with your Amazon Prime account to us
on Twitch and we get a few dollars of
Amazon's money and it's free to do it
it's free because you're already paying
for Amazon and their Prime subscription
here's a way that you can you can give
us monetary support go to patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez he'll be putting some
extra content over there while you're on
patreon.com visit my page at the Tony
Michaels just go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels and patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez that's how you can give us a
monetary support So this weekend I'll be
doing an ask me anything and a Sunday
rant I know Gabe has probably had some
events this
um this weekend so go check out our
patreon Pages
um that's how you can give us a monetary
sport but another three-way and there's
another free thing you can do it's free
share us share us on your social media
if you want a clip we'll get you a clip
share our Clips around you know what you
can do you do you can like this
broadcast wherever we broadcast Facebook
YouTube twitch you can like it you can
share it
so right now like like the broadcast and
keep tweeting at us keep participating
in the bonehead Madness this weekend
that's another way that helps us to get
our voices out there
so we can save our democracy folks we
have to do this we have to do this I
can't wait for Waco tomorrow you know
what I might do it depends I don't know
what time that [__] thing is are they
gonna air that thing live on Rumble is
that what they're gonna do
you want to do a um do you want to do a
joint patreon stream or something invite
or yeah drum members maybe we'll do that
maybe this weekend I'll do like a
patreon up we'll do a um
a link and we'll we'll uh for the
patreon members uh over there this
weekend let's see really quick Let's uh
hold on if we can figure out the time
and it works Trump cult he'll be he'll
be late yeah he usually goes yeah he's
he's obviously he's uh I wonder who he
will have to be like the
the my pillow gang the the lead-in my
pillow guy's always there on the side
he's like let's talk about voter fraud
you know right right right uh let's see
okay Waco Trump rally this is as of
okay Newsweek Donald Trump's Waco rally
risks turning into a disaster of course
well so they're not going to give the
time here's what we'll do here's what
we'll do we'll put our heads together
and figure out what time that thing is
what time we think Trump will and if we
can make it work
um maybe we'll do like a joint patreon
yeah where me and you
um invite the patreon members so go to
patreon.com the attorney Michaels or
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez check it
out maybe we'll do a stream tomorrow
we'll let you know on Twitter and rather
we'll be able to do a stream or not
everyone thanks for joining us for this
three hour episode and you jerks doing
your dick Shadows
you and your dick Shadows everyone
dialogue was too good I know I know I
know it's a great show great audience
best mods best audience and the best
host in the world and then to be quite
honest you know what I mean you know
what I mean your your favorite your
favorite host in the entire world okay I
got it I got it okay okay the event will
start at noon on Saturday but parking
lots will be welcoming guests for hours
early as 8 A.M the gates open at noon
preliminaries kick off at 2PM and the
former president who has made Waco is
kickoff point I thought Mar-A-Lago was
kickoff Point whatever his kickoff point
for 2024 campaign rallies is scheduled
to be speak 90 minutes beginning at 5
p.m so to be 7 00 p.m probably and
you'll speak for about he'll speak for
about I think 100 or 20 minutes wait
goes it's central time so that would be
5 p.m it didn't really here I'm yeah I
know but what I'm saying is oh two hours
later yeah I gotcha he's not gonna be on
it yeah okay okay well what will keep
you informed on Twitter yeah and on
patreon and if so if you want to uh join
patreon just go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check us out over there maybe
we'll stream this Waco this Waco wacko
we get a little wacko
ooh all right everyone
stay safe this weekend same time same
place on Monday Surfside [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon